Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Ich bin gespannt, wie du siehst.
Ich nimm's an sie.
Ich bin schon bei dir.
Ich bin schon bei dir. Ich bin schon bei dir. Bin ich nahe genug dran, Holger? Okay, Tobi, jetzt nimm die Hand da weg.
Ich hab noch mal so ein bisschen meine Computererfahrung des heutigen Tages zusammengefasst.
Ach so, die.
Du weißt schon.
Ja, herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio 71, liebe Höhrende.
Ja, du bist auch herzlich willkommen, Holger.
Ja, ich meinte nicht euch, euch meinte ich auch. Tim Tobias und der Ingenieur. Hier im Studio. Der Ingenieur bleibt heute incognito, denn der Ingenieur möchte nicht erkannt werden. Deshalb incognito. Worum geht es?
Es geht um Telefon.
Ach ne, wenn ich das gewusst hätte, wäre ich nicht gekommen.
Das hat doch jeder.
Es geht um Mobiltelefon. Das hat noch nicht ganz jeder. Ich glaube, die Deckung ist noch unter 99%.
Können wir da ein bisschen konkreter werden, bitte?
Na ja, es war ja gerade CeBIT. Weißt schon...
Warst du da? Ich bin einfach nicht hingegangen.
Also ich war kurz da. Sehr kurz. Das hat dann auch gereicht. Es war halt wie immer. Sie standen alle vor ihren komischen Ständen und mussten simulieren. Mussten so tun, als wäre alles gar nicht so schlimm. Vor allem mussten sie so tun, als hätten sie wieder alle ganz herausragende Produkte. Gerade im Mobilfunk-Bereich haben sie sich wieder richtig schön angestrengt. Nachdem sie alle selber eingesehen haben, dass sie mit ihrem Wappen nicht wirklich weit kommen, haben sich halt wieder neue 3-Buchstaben-Abkürzungen ausgedacht.
Manchmal auch 4 Buchstaben.
5 sogar jetzt auch schon. Auch da wird ein bisschen variiert. Aber im Kern ist noch nicht so sehr viel Neues dabei rübergekommen. Ein paar Sachen sind eigentlich nicht ganz wirklich uninteressant. Und wir wollen das heute mal ein bisschen auseinanderklammbüsern, was man von all diesen neuen Abkürzungen zu halten hat.
Ich kann dir mal kurz die neuen Abkürzungen vorlesen.
Aber nur die Abkürzung, nicht sagen, was es heißt.
Okay, das ist eine ganz beachtliche Liste. MMS, GPHS, UMTS, Imode, Hscsd, Bluetooth, Java, UMTS, ne, UMTS hatte ich schon. WAP, naja gut, WAP ist nicht mehr wirklich neu. Und so weiter. Das waren so die wichtigsten Basswörter. Genau, das gibt's gleich.
Chaosradio 71, Mobilfunk aktuell. Ja, fangen wir mit den neuen Abkürzungen MMS. Fangen wir mit MMS doch bitte an.
Multimedia Messaging Service.
Braucht kein Schwein, oder?
Wer weiß, ich meine, endlich können wir alle unsere Urlaubsfotos durch die ganze Welt schicken.
Ja, aber das ist doch, also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt schicke ich dir so eine Short-Message mit 100k, das dauert doch ewig, bis das Ding bei dir angekommen ist.
Du hast halt jetzt ein Telefon mit einer eingebauten Kamera, kannst das Ding irgendwie in Kuba am Strand gleich irgendwie auf die nächste beste prostituiert nutte, freiversiegbare Frau halten und sofort hast du irgendwie deine Urlaubsgrüße für deine Bekannten. Die haben das dann irgendwie 10 Sekunden später auf die Tüte.
Großartig, das muss ich machen, wenn ich im Urlaub bin.
Wir halten das wieder für vollkommen nutzlos, aber du weißt, wie das ist.
Ich glaube, es wird funktionieren. Ich meine, das ist doch das totale Angeber-Feature. Früher musste man einfach warten, bis man nach Hause kam, und Dias und irgendwie dann alle zum Dia-Abend einladen. Und irgendwie so jetzt kann man direkt, guckt mal, wo ich gerade bin.
Holiday Livestreaming.
Das Problem ist bloß, dass die wirklich Interessanten auf der Welt keine GSM-Abdeckung haben.
In Kuba wird es noch ein bisschen dauern.
Oder nicht mehr.
Wer denn noch nicht? Also was bezeichnest du als interessant, was keine GSM-Abdeckung hat?
Mexiko. Gibt es da nicht irgendetwas? Amerikas schwierig. Also in den USA gibt es das schon, aber in Amerika als Kontinent ist es ein bisschen mager.
Und was haben die? Nix.
Amerika hat irgendwie diverse Amps und D-Amps und TDMA und IS95 und CDMA und demnächst CDMA 2000.
Aber Multimedia Messaging ist jetzt das Ding der Zukunft, oder wie?
Ja, das ist total toll.
Also ist das so das, was Weihnachten dann durchbricht und alle wollen es haben?
Naja, ich schätze mal, Weihnachten noch nicht wirklich, aber das ist halt wie mit dem WAP. Man wird sich nicht wirklich dagegen wehren können. Also jeder hat heutzutage ein Telefon mit WAP-Browser und MMS wird halt auch in jedem Telefon drin sein, was ab in sechs Monaten oder so verkauft wird. Und was halt die Netzbetreiber damit machen wollen ist, also die SMS-Sache, das ist zwar, das boomt immer noch total, aber es gab jetzt gerade diverse Studien, die halt das Ende des SMS-Booms vorhergesagt haben und es ist halt schon, so diese 160 Zeichen ist halt nicht mehr so wirklich richtig viel. Und wovor die Netzbetreiber jetzt... Knistert?
Möchtest du saure Gurken haben?
Ich möchte saure Gurken haben.
Das sind immer Pommes frites. Wovor die Netzbetreiber jetzt Angst haben, ist, dass die Telefonhersteller jetzt alle prima E-Mail-Clients in ihre Telefone einbauen und die Leute dann statt SMS, weil da nur 160 Zeichen reingehen, einfach E-Mails durch die Gegend schicken und die mit ihrem Telefon lesen können.
Ja, aber das will man doch.
Ja, man schon, aber die Netzbetreiber wollen das nicht, weil sie dann daran nämlich nur noch die reinen Gebühren für die Datenübertragung verdienen. Und das ist halt einfach deutlich niedriger als dieser tolle, bisher, was wir da haben, 39 Pfennig oder 20 Cent oder 19 Cent, wie viel das jetzt auch immer ist, für 160 Zeichen. Das ist einfach die Netzbetreiber machen, wie viel, ich glaube, irgendwie so.
Na, da kostet der Megabyte immerhin 2500 Mark.
Genau, Preise...
So habe ich das halt mal nie geregt, das ist ja bitter.
Also im TK-Bereich ist es halt sowieso, da wird irgendwie noch die Luft verkauft, so, nicht? Man redet ja auch von Airtime, die da irgendwie verkauft wird, und so ähnlich ist es halt auch, als müsste man halt ihr Sauerstoff auch mieten.
Aber ich finde, so den Vergleich, ein Gigabyte für, was, 2500 Mark? Megabyte, verzeihung, ein Megabyte.
Aber 2, 5 Millionen Mark für ein Gigabyte.
2, 5 Millionen Mark, im Vergleich zu vielleicht 60 Mark, die du irgendwie beim Internet-Service brauchst.
Wann war das, wo man für eine Gigabyte-Festplatte 2, 5 Millionen Mark bezahlt hat?
In den 60ern?
Telekommunikation ist sowieso noch viel zu teuer. Es ist immer noch irgendwie viel, viel, viel billiger, sich Festplatten zu kaufen, die Daten darauf zu speichern und das Ganze mit der Post zu verschicken.
Ja, wenn es ankommt oder nicht kaputt gemacht wird, weil alles, was man mit der Post schickt, was sensibel ist, geht grundsätzlich unterwegs kaputt und die Post zahlt nicht.
Du kannst es redundant machen. Du kannst ja auch noch 10 Festplatten kaufen, die parallel verschicken. Eine kommt schon, andere sind immer noch billiger.
Jetzt muss man nur noch eine Informations- Habe dir Daten geschickt. Kannst du irgendwann mal aufhören dich zu Rolls-Band? Oder hast du die Rolls-Band-Taste gefunden, jedes Mal wenn du drauf drückst?
Ich möchte forcieren, dass du sie findest.
Tim Biolake.
Chaosradio 71 hier. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Bei der Konvergenz.
Konvergenz.
Ja, das musste ich gerade wieder auf Plakaten lesen.
Konvergenz?
Naja, dieses MMS ist da ein ganz gutes Beispiel. Was sie ja jetzt gemacht haben ist, deswegen heißt es ja auch Multimedia-Messaging, sozusagen andere Datentypen zu erlauben und nun hätten sie da ganz TK-mäßig vorgehen können, wie sie es früher gemacht haben und dicke fette den A4-Druckwerke entwickeln können, wie man denn das so macht.
Und doch, das haben sie getan.
Ja, beim Kern ist es doch Mime.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ja eben, da steht also nur drin, lesen sie bitte das RFC. Aber sie haben alles kopiert.
Also im Prinzip ist es so, jeder E-Mail-Client kann prima MMS anzeigen. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch das, was man haben möchte. Man möchte eigentlich E-Mail auf seinem Telefon haben. Und die Einzigen, die das nicht wollen, sind halt die Netzbetreiber, weil die dann irgendwie nichts mehr dran verdienen oder so gut wie nichts mehr. Weil diese Umsätze und vor allen Dingen die Gewinne, die die mit SMS machen, das ist einfach total unbeschlagen. Das lässt sich nie wieder, nie können 160 Bytes so teuer verkauft werden.
Hast du da Zahlen im Kopf?
Ich glaube, was habe ich gerade neulich gelesen?
Irgendwie 25 Prozent macht das aus, ne, von ihrem Umsatz?
Nee, nicht ganz so viel, aber es sind irgendwie 18 sind es glaube ich.
Ach, vielen.
Ja, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, bloß mit diesen scheiß 160 Zeichen-Nachrichten. Und das ist halt ein gewaltiger Markt. Und deshalb, damit ihnen das nicht verloren geht, versuchen sie das Ganze jetzt halt mit MMS weiterlaufen zu lassen. Und irgendwie, ja, dementsprechend, weil E-Mail ja die logische Konsequenz wäre. Sie das aber nicht machen können, haben sie sich jetzt halt ein bisschen was anderes überlegt. Okay, ich meine, es ist halt nicht nur E-Mail, sie benutzen da dieses Smile-Sprache. Was? S-M-I-L geschrieben.
Aber man soll Smile sagen.
Genau.
Was Smile heißt.
Das ist eine XML-basierte Sprache.
Wollt nur kurz die Choräle anklinken lassen.
Kann ich noch ein paar von den Gurken haben?
Das ist eine XML-basierte Sprache, die nicht nur erlaubt zu sagen, da kommt jetzt ein Bild und da unten steht ein Text, sondern die ist auch noch zeitlich definiert. Man kann sozusagen eine Slideshow machen.
Ach so, die verfällt irgendwann.
Im Prinzip ist das, was man so von Flash und so etwas kennt, das wird man auch so kund.
Reel benutzt das, glaube ich.
Ja, Reel ist auch ganz erheblich mit ganz vorne bei der Smiling-Bewirkung.
Also du kannst halt sagen, erst dieses Bild hier anzeigen, dann irgendwie das 5 Sekunden stehen lassen, dann den Text, dann spielst du den Sound ein, währenddessen irgendwie die nächsten Bilder und so was in der Art halt.
Weil diese typischen Webseiten-Intros, die kein Mensch sehen will.
Die darf man sicher auch im Handy angucken. Und was kostet es denn?
Das hat sich noch niemand so recht getraut, irgendwie was zu sagen. Also Netzbetreiber wagen halt alle, keiner traut sich als erster, irgendwas zu sagen. Deshalb D2 wollte, also Wodafone, wie sie jetzt heißen, wollten aber trotzdem den Anfang machen und deshalb haben sie jetzt letzten Donnerstag gesagt, so, MMS ist jetzt ganz offiziell bei uns gestartet. Das kann jetzt jeder benutzen und irgendwie, wir trauen uns aber nicht, irgendwelche Preise zu sagen, deshalb ist es bis Ende Juli erstmal kostenlos. Erstmal anfixen, so haben sie es bei SMS auch gemacht.
Stimmt, da E plus war das anfangs kostenlos.
Am Anfang hat es halt auch nicht besonders gut funktioniert.
Irgendwann hat irgendwer diese komische E-Gate-Geschichte da gemacht, die denen die SMS-Cs breit gemacht hat und dann hat es plötzlich Kohle gekostet.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wie ist dieses gesamte SMS-Feature überhaupt in das Protokoll seinerzeit reingekommen? Dann müssen sie den, der das seinerzeit mit reingenommen hat, doch heute noch mit Gold überschütten.
Das war ganz ursprünglich, glaube ich, mal als irgendeine Wartungsgeschichte gedacht. Das ist sicher?
Das ist nicht der Nachfolger von dieser User-to-User-Info?
Nee, nee, das hat damit nichts zu tun. Das gibt es ja User-to-User-Singling gibt es ja trotzdem noch.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Das ist so ein Teil von ISDN und im Prinzip ist GSM heißt auch MISDN, also Mobile ISDN. Das ist so von der ganzen Protokollstruktur sehr verwandt. Also es gibt nicht so richtig sehr viele Unterschiede. Es gibt natürlich sehr viel Mobilfunk spezifisches, was hinzugekommen ist, aber im Kern haben sie die gleiche Idee weiterentwickelt.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht, ich wollte nur...
Na ja, jetzt haben wir gleich alle ausgegessen. Und dann haben wir auch wieder mehr Kraft.
Dann krieg ich noch eins. Willst du noch eins? Dann nehmen wir zwei.
Komm mal rein.
Also das ist halt dieses wenig sehr teuer verkaufen, ist einfach im TK-Bereich schon immer so gewesen. Ich mein, das sehen wir einfach auch beim Telefonieren. Das kostet einfach zu viel Geld. Das, was so gemeinhin abgerechnet wird, ist einfach nicht angemessen. Ich denke, das kann jeder auch nachvollziehen, der so ein bisschen seine Endgeräte auch benutzt. Die Margen, die irgendwie die TK-Firmen halt sich gönnen, schon seit Ewigkeiten dadurch, dass sie eben auch diese Monopolstellung haben, die, also oder, naja, jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben von Monopolstellung zu reden, aber in den Kuchenteilen sich halt wenige, bitte?
Ist es keine Monopolstellung?
In Teilen ist es halt noch eine richtige, was insbesondere die Telekom betrifft.
Das ist so eine Art Kartell, wie die Mineralekonzerne auch.
Ja gut, das kommt dir damals an, als der Markt dereguliert wurde und die Preise für USA-Gespräche auf einmal um 90 Prozent fielen.
Genau, das ist irgendwie so das beste Beispiel, da wo es halt wirkliche Konkurrenz gibt und es halt nicht mehr so ein Oligopol gibt von Unternehmen, die sich untereinander absprechen können, wie das halt bei den Mobilfunkbetreibern ist. Ich vermute nicht mal, dass sie sich untereinander absprechen, da guckt halt einer, was macht der andere und dann wird das halt genauso gemacht. Das sieht man halt jetzt auch bei MMS, keiner traut sich so richtig irgendwas zu sagen. Es gab tatsächlich eine Aussage von D2, die Pricing-Modelle sollen so sein, es wird halt nach Größe abgerechnet. Am Anfang kann eine Nachricht ähnlich größer als 30 Kilobyte sein, was ja schon mal ein ganzes Stück größer ist als die 160 Zeichen von bisher.
Vor allem werden die sie auch garantiert dem Empfänger auch noch abnehmen, ne?
Sie haben sich schon überlegt, sie haben sich halt tatsächlich hingesetzt und haben sich überlegt, was machen wir, damit wir weiterhin so viel Kohle verdienen. Und kein Mensch würde MMS benutzen, wenn du irgendwie das anschaltest, dann werden dir Nachrichten geschickt und du musst dafür irgendwie undefiniert Kohle zahlen. So und deshalb machen sie das so. Nur dem Absender wird das halt in Rechnung gestellt. Und D2 hat gesagt, die größte Nachricht wird nicht mehr als 39 Cent kosten.
Wenn Fritz rund um Kurtbus, dann 103, 2.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Heute Nacht Wolken, Regen, 9 bis 6 Grad morgen. Manchmal Sonne, bei 16 bis 19 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
So, das ging ja fix. Die Anschaffung des Transportflugzeuges A400M hat erneut für ein Eklat im Haushaltsausschuss gesorgt. Die Ausschussmitglieder warfen Verteidigungsminister Scharping vor, mit finanziellen Zusagen an die Partnerstaaten den Willen des Parlaments missachtet zu haben. Der grünen Haushaltsexperte Metzger forderte den Rücktritt Scharpings. Die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden haben ein weiteres mutmaßliches Mitglied der palästinensischen Islamistenorganisation Al-Tahit festgenommen. Der Verdächtige soll morgen dem Ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt werden. Die Gruppe steht im Verdacht, terroristische Anschläge vorbereitet zu haben. Die niederländische Justiz hat vier Algerier unter dem Verdacht der Zugehörigkeit zu einer islamischen, terroristischen Organisation in Haft genommen. Wie ein Behördensprecher mitteilte, sollen sie zu einer Gruppe gehören, die in Algerien und im Ausland Anschläge verübt hat. Das tschechische Parlament hat eine Streichung der Benes-Dekrete und eine Eigentumsrückgabe an Sudetendeutsche abgelehnt. Mit großer Mehrheit verabschiedete es eine Resolution, in der die Verordnungen als Folge des Zweiten Weltkrieges bezeichnet werden. Die Entschließung war eine Reaktion auf Forderungen. Prag müsse vor einem EU-Beitritt die Dekrete streichen. Die Arbeitslosigkeit wird in Deutschland noch etliche Jahre lang hoch bleiben. Zu diesem Schluss kommt die Enquete-Kommission demografischer Wandel. In ihrem Abschlussbericht durch die Bevölkerungsentwicklung wird es nach Ansicht der Experten erst 2015 weniger Erwerbslose geben. Sport, Fußball im Halbfinale-Hinspiel der Champions League steht es kurz vor Schluss zwischen Manchester United und Bayer Leverkusen 2 zu 2, 90 Minuten und 31 Sekunden gespielt. Außerdem Basketball. Aber Berlin hat heute das 2. Playoff-Viertelfinale gewonnen gegen die Bayer Giants Leverkusen, und zwar mit 92 zu 87. Damit werden wir beim Verkehr auf Fritz. Ich habe keine aktuellen Meldungen und wünsche deshalb eine gute Fahrt.
Der Tag der offenen Tür beim ORB.
Wo Fritz ja dazugehört wird.
Am 1. Mai, sind es Mittwoch von 10 bis 18 Uhr.
Mit einem riesen Aufgebot von...
Dingen! Ja, das ist total out.
Ja, das ist total out. Vor allen Dingen hat unser Ingenieur, Entschuldigung, DER Ingenieur, gerade ungeheure Probleme mit dem Mikrofon zu platzieren. Vor... geht's denn?
Alles im Lot.
Dem Ingenieur ist nichts zu schwören.
Super geil, hier gibt es jetzt so eine Borg-Lampe direkt dran. Also man muss mal dazu erklären, hier ist ja ein neues Studio. Also es war auch schon bei der letzten Chaosradio-Sendung irgendwie, aber da waren wir alle noch nicht da.
Ja und das Rotlicht, das sind keine Lampen mehr, sondern so Lichtleiter, die in Plexiglas münden. Sieht irre aus, ne?
Ja voll Borg-mäßig irgendwie.
Das würde mich diese Maschine hier irgendwie angucken.
Vielleicht verspeist sie mich. Asimiliert sie mich auch, Michel.
Chaosradio 71 ist hier. Guten Abend. Wir reden über Telefone.
Genau und den Widerstand ist zwecklos Faktor bei großen TK-Firmen.
Wer erst mal was sagt, hat verloren.
Na dann fange ich mal an, was sich immer am Messagetyp ändert, egal ob SMS oder EMS oder was auch immer. Was sicherlich gleich bleibt bei Motorola ist, dass wenn eine SMS oder MMS oder was auch immer reinkommt und die Tastensperre aktiviert ist, auch sicherlich beim neuen S, wie heißt das? A820 oder das UMTS-Handy?
A820, das sind jetzt EMS. Kann mir noch mal einer sagen, was EMS ist?
EMS war so ein hilfloser Versuch von allen Telefonherstellern außer Nokia, so ein Zwischendings zwischen SMS und MMS zu machen, was vollkommen auf SMS basiert und so tolle Sachen machen kann, wie da kannst du Bilder versenden und Töne versenden und irgendwie den Text formatieren und fett und kursiv und andere Farben und so. Und da Nokia das ja schon längere Zeit mit seinem Smart Messaging hat und die anderen Telefonhersteller sich aber zu schade waren, das in ihre eigenen Telefone zu implementieren, haben sie sich halt was eigenes überlegt. Und das ist halt EMS, das haben jetzt die meisten Telefone von Siemens, Alcatel, Motorola, Ericsson und so, die können das halt alle, aber es benutzt halt kein Mensch.
Also das ist das, wo ich jetzt mit meinem Siemens dann eine 760 zeichenlange Short-Message schicken kann, angeblich, die dann in 28 Teile geteilt wird und bei irgendeinem Harmschwein. Ein altes Handy oder ein anderes Handy hat...
Das ist sogar ganz normal nur SMS. Das ist tatsächlich im SMS-Sandart definiert. Das nennt sich Concatenated Short-Messages. Da werden halt mehrere SMS ineinander gehackt und Telefone, die das unterstützen, die zeigen die dann halt tatsächlich auch als eine SMS an.
Der Ingenieur jetzt bitte wieder.
Genau, wie gesagt, es wäre noch interessant, ob sie bei UMTS-Handys von Motorola endlich mal schaffen, den Tastensperren-Bug herauszubekommen, dass wenn eine SMS eingeht und die Tastensperre aktiviert ist, das Telefon sagt SMS lesen, ja, nein, und man drückt ja. Und dann sagt das Telefon aber nicht, hier ist die SMS, sondern sie haben die Tastensperre aktiviert und die SMS verschwindet. Sie versinkt in ominösen Untermenüs, durch die man dann mit 27 Tasten drücken muss, um wieder an die SMS zu kommen. Haben sie seit ca. 5 Jahren. In ungefähr 10 verschiedenen Softwareversionen.
Da zeigt sich auch ein bisschen die dunkle Bedrohung, die durch dieses Aufbohren von den bisher herrschenden Standards kommt. Gerade bei den MMS sehe ich schon wieder Buffer-Overflow und irgendwie begrenzte Speicher. Diese Handys sind ja nun mal keine voll ausgestatteten Desktop-PCs mit irgendwie unendlich viel Festplatte oder RAM. Und die haben ja schon ihre Probleme mit eingehenden Daten. Die Null-of-Service-Attacken sind ja auch jetzt schon recht verbreitet.
Ich habe das heute gerade mal probiert. Ich habe hier so ein T68i, das bisher einzige am Markt erhältliche Telefon, das MMS empfangen und versenden kann. Und es gelingt einem problemlos mit einer MMS, wo man diese Smile-Formatierung, ein paar falsche Texte reinschreibt, um das Telefon zum Absturz zu bringen. Wenn man sich hier mal auf Anzeigen geht, geht das Telefon erst mal aus. Dann kommt es wieder hoch und sagt Pin eingeben. Dann gibt man die Pin ein und es geht gleich erst mal wieder aus.
Das ist irgendwie schade.
Das soll ja durchaus auch bei anderen Telefonen mit anderen Formaten vorkommen.
Bei Nokia damals 160 Punkte schicken war damals irgendwie das beliebte Spiel.
Bei Nokia gibt es ja immer noch diesen tollen Bug. Jetzt in den ganz neuen Telefonen nicht mehr, aber Nokia-Telefone kannst du einfach so sank und klanglos abstürzen lassen mit SMSen. Da schreibst du einfach bestimmte Sachen rein. Dann steht das Telefon und man kriegt es nicht mehr mit. Das Beste ist sogar, wenn man...
Man kann sie doch drei Tage lang freezen, oder?
Ja, was das lustigste ist, wenn jemand gerade telefoniert und man schickt ihm während er telefoniert so eine SMS, dann freezt das Telefon bzw. das User-Interface. Aber die GSM-Engine läuft weiter. Das heißt, derjenige kann weiter telefonieren, kann aber keine Tasten mehr bedienen. Wenn derjenige dann auflegt bzw. denkt, er hätte aufgelegt, telefoniert er weiter. Das ist unangenehm. Eine 1A-Spionage-Einrichtung.
Wie kriege ich das weg? Akku ab, Akku dran und dann geht es wieder? Oder ist es ein für alle Mal tot und ich muss es software update machen?
Nee, das nicht. Akku ab und Akku wieder ran hilft in vielen Fällen, aber nicht in allen. Das kommt immer darauf an, in welchem Land, in welchem Netz, mit welcher Softwareversion, von welchem Telefon du gerade bist. Aber im Prinzip hilft bei Nokia da nur noch ein neueres Telefon kaufen.
Also es gab einen recht netten Bug bei Nokia, speziell für 33er und 62er. Wenn man eine spezielle SMS empfangen hat, dann ist das Telefon abgestürzt und das Netz hat aber vom Telefon nicht bestätigt bekommen, dass diese zum Absturz führende SMS ausgeliefert wurde vom Netz an das Telefon. Dann ist das Telefon neu gestartet, hat gerebootet, das Telefon war wieder ins Netz eingebucht, sofort hat das Netz gesehen, das Telefon ist wieder online, hat die SMS wieder geschickt, hat keine Bestätigung bekommen, das Telefon ist wieder abgeschmiert und nach drei Tagen hat das Netz die SMS dann gelöscht. Aber die ersten drei Tage hatte man dann schon mal schliss die Laune.
Ich schreibe mir bitte das alles auf den Zettel, was ich da schicken muss. Eine Menge Kollegen haben Nokia hin.
Ja, das geht übrigens für alle Nokia-Telefone vor dem 6310 und dem 8310. Also egal, ob 6210, 6150, 3310, 30 und die Communicator, 7110, alles total egal.
Mit einem erheblichen Marktanteil, insbesondere in Deutschland.
Also sind es so geringfügig über 10%?
Bisschen. Ein bisschen Und da schreibst du einfach in deine SMS rein slash slash scke2 begin doppelpunkt vcard enter Also E-N-T-E-R. Nein, enter als Zeichen. Carriage return. Genau, du brauchst ein Telefon. Genau, du brauchst ein Telefon, das kommt bei SMS aufs Gleiche raus. Du brauchst ein Telefon, was sozusagen einen Line Feed oder einen Carriage Return erzeugen kann. So, Doppelpunkt, wieder Enter, End, Doppelpunkt, V-Card. Das war's. Lass mich überlegen. Oder Carriage Return Line Feed? Nein, es ist Carriage Return.
So, möglicherweise möchte das hier jemand ausprobieren, an natürlich seinem eigenen Telefon, an das er sich von einem anderen eigenen Telefon aus einer entsprechenden Kurznachricht sendet. Wenn ihr das dann ausprobiert habt, besorgt euch ein anderes Telefon, ruft mal hier an und dann 0331 7791 und erzählt, wie es war.
Und nicht traurig sein, wenn ihr einen Siemens habt, zum Beispiel einen S45 oder einen ME45, dann könnt ihr anstelle von lustigen SMS-Schreiben doch einfach mal in den Kalender gucken. Und wenn euer Telefon dann ganz unvermittelt ausgeht, dann habt ihr wohl eine alte Software-Version.
Genau, die gibt es dann auf der Siemens-Homepage, um runterzuladen, also irgendwie ein GPRS-Update, das auch wundersamerweise den Kalender repariert, aber Siemens schreibt das auf seiner Homepage nicht, dass man damit vielleicht den Kalender reparieren könnte. Dazu muss man dann wieder irgendwie Heise lesen oder so um sowas zu lesen.
Ja, und was denn da ja, was man sich da wieder für neue interessante Bugs einfängt. Also wir kommen jetzt auch wirklich so langsam in die Zeit, wie diese Telefonen eben so viel können wollen, was irgendwie alles schon gar nicht mehr so richtig handhabbar ist, weil die auch noch nicht so richtig getestet werden. Der Sport, der jetzt eigentlich eingeleitet wird, das ist so, wenn ich mir das alles anschaue, ist so ein bisschen die erweiterte Heim-Spionage. Also Spionage fürs Volk. Also man hat halt ein Telefon, da ist eine Kamera drin, das kann auch sofort irgendwie ein Foto senden. Das Teil brauchst du eigentlich nur noch irgendwo am Draht in der Ecke aufzuhängen hinterm Netz. So und dann richtig programmiert und richtig gescriptet, das wird alles kommen, liefert das Ding einfach regelmäßig Bilder. Das kann natürlich so die Baby-Überwachung sein und alles irgendwie gewollt sein, aber neben Babys lassen sich natürlich auch andere Dinge überwachen.
Babysitter-Überwachung. Es ist ja wiederum so teuer, diese Daten zu verschicken, dass sich das kein Schwein leisten kann.
Ja gut, aber eine gute Scheidung kann ja heutzutage auch schon eine Menge Geld einbringen. Von daher refinanziert sich das unter Umständen wieder.
Tja, Herbehörden Mädels. Chaosradio 71 auf Fritz, wir sind gerade bei Abkürzungen gewesen. Was hatten wir jetzt? MMS hatten wir, dann machen wir WAP. Weil ja auch gerade Tobias so hübsch ins Internet gerade mit seinem Handy mit WAP.
Ja, super.
Finde ich gut, dass du WAP benutzt, Tobias.
Die erste komplett kabellose Internetaktion hier bei Chaosradio.
Tatsächlich, wie bist du jetzt drin?
Ich bin jetzt nicht über WAP, sondern über GPS und Bluetooth drin mit meinem Laptop.
Was heißt, du hast jetzt Bluetooth in deinem Laptop?
In meinem Laptop ist Bluetooth eingebaut.
Was ist da drin?
Ja, das ist eingebaut.
Echt? A30P, wenn wir mal keine Verbungen machen würden.
A30P von wem?
Von IBM.
Gibt er immer noch so furchtbare Lautsprecher?
Nee, die sind inzwischen echt richtig besser geworden.
Das ist aber doch scheiß teuer, oder? Was zahlst du da für einen K?
Da zahle ich für einen K so ungefähr einen Pfennig.
Ja, aber das ist aber günstig.
Nee, das ist nicht günstig. Wenn du mal nachdenkst...
Also gemessen daran, was alle anderen zahlen müssen, ist das extrem günstig. Also ich zahle für einen K einen Cent.
Bei welchem Netzbetreiber bist du?
SMS kostet einen K 250.
Hören Sie mal auf zu unkeln da.
Okay, also du hast Bluetooth eingebaut und das Telefon hat auch Bluetooth eingebaut.
Ganz genau.
Also Bluetooth ist halt diese neue kommende Schnittstelle.
Kabel, Kabel ohne Kabel.
Wie heißt das so schön? Personal Area Network.
Genau. So Instant Hodenkrebs oder so.
Das ist so die permanente Aura, mit der man irgendwie seine Businesskarten durch die Gegend funken kann. Das ist sicherlich irgendwie das Sicherheitsloch der Zukunft. Man braucht einfach nur noch irgendwie mit einem entsprechenden Bluetooth-Scanner in den Omnibus einzusteigen und kommt bestimmt mit lustigen Daten wieder heraus. Trotzdem ist es natürlich an sich erstmal eine Technik, die man auch haben will, weil man eben überhaupt gar keine Kabel mehr braucht.
Das ist halt schon eine ganz nette Sache. Das Problem ist halt, man hat ja seinen Laptop nicht immer dabei. Also dieses Teil ist irgendwie auch schwer und irgendwie so, das will man halt auch nicht überall mit hinschleppen und deshalb ist ja die Idee von dem Internet, das man immer dabei hat, so im Handy, die ist ja eigentlich mal gar nicht so schlecht gewesen. Bloß die Umsetzung ist halt eine Katastrophe.
Ja, schwarz-weiß, schwarz-weiß und langsam.
Schwarz-weiß, langsam, teuer, langweilig. Und irgendwie, was uns die Netzbetreiber da vor zwei oder drei Jahren versprochen haben, jetzt wird alles toll und wir kriegen die ganze Zeit nur noch im Internet mit unserem Telefon und so. Ich weiß nicht, also ich benutze das kaum und ich glaube irgendwie, ich glaube kein Schwein benutzt das.
Bluetooth mit GPRS oder WAP?
WAP.
Bluetooth mit GPRS benutzt man. Ich benutze das manchmal, also wenn ich zum Beispiel irgendwo in einer fremden Stadt bin und wissen will, wie ich mit dem nächsten Zug nach Hause komme, dann funktioniert das ganz gut.
Ja, für Bahnauskünfte geht es inzwischen, aber sonst so, ich meine, ich habe neulich mal versucht, Kino irgendwie rauszufinden, was abends im Kino läuft, das ging irgendwie gar nicht. Habe ich erstmal Ewigkeiten gesucht, dann habe ich da irgendwie Zeit von ich glaube Cinemax oder so gefunden und habe versucht, eine Vorstellung rauszufinden und dann musste man sich durch alle Filme einzeln durchklicken.
Und das Ticket war nach einer halben Stunde schon 30 Euro teuer?
Genau, so sieht das aus.
Man hat auch überhaupt keine Kostenkontrolle, das ist auch ein grundsätzliches Problem. Bestimmte Techniken und Zugangstechnologien werden sich einfach erst durchsetzen, wenn sie entweder kostenlos oder grundsätzlich so billig sind, dass man auch bei Heavy-Use nicht damit rechnen muss, dass man gleich ins armen Haus geht.
Nur wollen wir mal kurz eine Beinfachkarte laufen. Short-Messaging ist Schweineteuer und es wird Heavy-Use.
Das ist die Killer-Applikation. Short-Messaging ist die Killer-Applikation. WAP hast du halt, wie du schon sagtest, schwarz-weiß. Lange ich mal, SMS ist auch schwarz-weiß, aber SMS soll auch nichts anderes sein. Jetzt wird es farbig, bisher ist es halt schwarz-weiß. Und es ist langsam gewesen, das ändert sich jetzt auch.
Aber Farbe braucht keiner.
Und was halt wirklich das Abschlussargument war, es gibt halt kein Angebot. Und es funktioniert oft nicht.
Mit diesen Messages, das ist wirklich komisch, das ist eigentlich keiner begreift. Auch im Internet. Es gab ja unglaublich viele Dienste im Internet schon aus frühen Zeiten, die da schon etabliert waren. Da wusste irgendwie jeder Bescheid. Es gab Chat, es gab Mail, es gab Newsgroups und das gibt es ja auch heute noch. Dann kam das Web dazu. Alles super und alles hat sich im Prinzip auch schon aus der Kultur des Webbs so mit den alten Leuten, der alten Garde heraus entwickelt. Nur eine einzige Anwendung kam erst sehr viel später und hat alle überrascht, mich und das auch, dass dieses Instant-Messaging, also sowas wie ICQ und so, also dieses Bedürfnis der Leute, sich ad hoc mal eben mit einer kurzen Information online so schnell wie möglich auszutauschen, das ist einfach sehr groß. In dem Moment, wo es mehr Handys geben wird, die man damit aufklappen kann mit Text und dann eben diesen GPRS und billigem Internetzugang, wird sich einfach Chat weiter durchsetzen, weil das ist auch jetzt schon die Anwendung, das wollen die Leute im Prinzip auch auf dem Handy. Man will halt irgendwie einfach immer irgendwie mit irgendjemanden verbunden sein.
Ist das so? Also willst du das auf dem Handy?
Ja natürlich, warum denn nicht? Das ist super gut, einfach um mit Leuten in Kontakt zu bleiben. Ich könnte jetzt hier, könnte ich jetzt irgendwie mein Handy aufklappen und ich wäre irgendwie jetzt im Chaosradio-Chat drin oder könnte mich noch mit zwei, drei anderen Leuten irgendwie verbinden, die wir zum Thema was beizutragen haben. Man kann ja auch sehr ökonomisch arbeiten mit Chat, man kann einfach ignorieren, aber man kann auch schnell die notwendige Information generieren. Genau deswegen sind diese Instant-Messaging-Geschichten auch ganz gut. Dieses WAP war einfach von Anfang an ein Tod gebohrt. Erstmal ist es irgendwie, wie es technisch aufgebaut ist, ist es im Prinzip nichts anderes als so ein Bildschirmtext-Klon. Ja, es hat so ein bisschen mehr was mit Formularen zu tun, damit sieht man eben auch welche Mentalität eigentlich in diesem Bereich, da in diesem Ingenieursbereich, ist in diesem TK-Film, denk einfach anders. Und es war vor allem komplett am WAP vorbei. Also WAP ist ja mehrere Sachen in einem, da kann man das auch immer gleich schnell mit irgendwelchen Dingen verwechseln. Das wurde ja auch so als der Halsbringer generell gemacht. Aber im Prinzip stellt es eine Alternative zum WAP da, bis hin zu den einzelnen Protokollen. Das heißt, es wird überhaupt nichts benutzt, was im Web langsam omnipräsent ist. So HTTP, HTTPS, HTML, also wirklich das, was universelle Sprache wird gerade, hat WAP einfach mal jede einzelne Komponente ein bisschen anders gemacht. Um letzten Endes genau das Gleiche zu machen, ist klar, dass da keiner irgendwelche Energie reinsteckt.
Naja, der Punkt ist halt, dass da schon HTTP benutzt wird. Bloß auf der Schnittstelle zwischen dem Telefon und dem WAP Gateway, da gibt es WTP und WSP, weil sie das für den Traffic optimieren wollten. Wenn du dir die ganzen HTTP-Header anguckst, das ist halt nicht auf Traffic optimiert. WTP und WML, diese Seitenbeschreibungssprache, die kannst du halt beidkompilieren und das war halt schon mal...
Damit drängen sie das Ganze halt in einen fixen Zustand rein und nur diese Flexibilität hat diese Protokolle so erfolgreich gemacht. Man sieht ja, was jetzt passiert mit WAP. Es wird einfach ignoriert und erst mal wird keiner mehr davon reden und dann wird es komplett fallen gelassen und dann wird es weg sagen.
Naja, ganz so ist es nicht. Also WAP wird weiterhin benutzt werden. Das war halt damals dieses WAP 1.0 bzw. 1.1, das konnte man halt einfach nicht benutzen. Und was jetzt halt kommt, das wird halt bunt und es wird schnell und das wird dann irgendwann auch funktionieren. Und wie das letztlich heißt, ob das dann Imode heißt oder ob das WAP ist, MMS funktioniert ja zum Beispiel auch nur über WAP. Also MMS benutzt WAP-Protokolle, um versendet zu werden und...
Das würde dann ja aber bedeuten, dass dann frühe oder späte MMS doch wieder tot ist, also wirklich nur so ein Zwischenstadium.
Nö, gar nicht.
Wenn ich sowieso neues WAP kriege, was schneller und bunter ist?
Das ist einfach eine andere Anwendung.
Nee, das ist eine andere Anwendung. Das ist ja wie MMS ist wie E-Mail und WAP ist wie Webklicken. Genau. Und deshalb, also das wird halt kommen, welche Protokolle da letztlich drunter liegen, das ist eigentlich relativ egal, weil die Themen schüttelt den Kopf.
Ich sehe es ein bisschen anders, aber es ist nicht so wichtig, dass wir uns da drüber groß auslassen müssen. Also ich sehe es einfach klar kommen, dass es einfach ausschließlich das, was im WAP-Standard ist, wird auch im TK-Bereich Standard werden. Also wenn du WAP anschaust, da gibt es einfach den entsprechenden Gegenspieler im HTML-Bereich, das ist die Modularisierung des HTML-Standards, also XHTML.
Naja, aber du redest von WML. WML wird verschwinden.
Das ist richtig, aber auch die anderen Protokolle sind im Prinzip überflüssig, weil dieses ganze WTP und so weiter versucht halt exakt genau das gleiche zu machen wie HTTP, bloß dass sie irgendwie ein paar Sachen sagen, naja, okay, wenn es so ist, dann schreiben wir das bald. Damit sparen sich ein paar Sachen. Das kannst du aber genauso gut mit einer ordentlichen Kompression genauso klein kriegen.
Du wirst das beide überhaupt nicht mehr trennen können, weil du hast auf beiden Seiten einen Computer. Der Computer auf der Telekommunikationszeit ist das Telefon. Zuhause ist es der PC. Und du hast eine Datenübertragung und ob die nun über Leitung oder über Funk ist, kommt doch selber raus. Und in zwei Jahren werden Geschwindigkeiten gleich sein und dann gibt es keine Trennung mehr. Und über kurze Zeit lang werden die Kabel sowieso wegfliegen und das ist alles über Funk.
Genau deswegen glaube ich auch, dass sich eben einfach die Web-Standards durchsetzen werden, weil niemand implementiert WAP auf dem desktop PC. Nur auf Handys gibt es das. So, aber auf Handys wird es auch HTTP, auch HTTPS, auch HTML geben müssen, zwangsläufig, weil das eben genau mit den wachsenden Bandbreiten und sinkenden Preisen irgendwann kein Thema mehr ist. Da muss man nichts Neues erfinden.
Ja, aber warte mal, du, was du da halt, der Punkt ist, als Anbieter machst du, als Content-Anbieter machst du, auch wenn du WAP-Angebote hast, nur HTTP und HTTPS, weil es da die entsprechenden WAP-Gegenstücke gibt und dass diese WAP-Geschichte, diese WAP-Protokolle, die werden bloß zwischen dem Telefon und dem WAP-Gateway gesprochen. Was danach kommt, das sind genau diese ganzen WAP-Standards. Ob das irgendwann ausgetauscht wird gegen die WAP-Standards, weil man den WAP-Kram nicht mehr braucht, das ist total egal. Aber das wird noch irgendwie ein paar Jahre lang weiter benutzt werden und du wirst davon nichts merken. Was verschwinden wird, ist dieses hässliche Etwas, was wir als WAP kennengelernt haben, was halt in Wirklichkeit WML und WML-Skript ist. Das, was wir kennen. So, diese ganzen Protokolle darunter, die werden noch eine ganze Zeit weiterleben.
Die werden jetzt noch ein bisschen vor sich hin darben, aber sie haben halt keine Zukunft. Da bin ich einfach überzeugt.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Chaosradio 71 und wir haben einen Anrufer hier, er geht zum Handys und deswegen ruft er auch an. Hallo Christian. Hallo.
Schildere dein Problem.
Ich wollte dich noch mal fragen, ob man in der SMS stehen sollte, damit das Handy abstürzt.
Das haben wir ja schon mal gesagt.
Das haben wir aus dokumentarischen Zwecken oder Gründen einmal gesagt, das können wir jetzt natürlich nicht wiederholen, weil das wäre dann eine Aufforderung zumindest zur Nötigung.
Ich wollte meine Handy mal ausprobieren, ob das klappen würde, wirste.
Wirklich nur mit deinem Telefon wolltest du es ausprobieren?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt... Tobias, kannst du kurz deine Adresse und deinen Nachnamen durchgeben?
Aber man findet das natürlich auch im Web.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, soll ich das jetzt noch mal irgendwie sagen?
Gibt es sich irgendwie eine Seite, wo das jetzt albern ist? Also wenn wir das jetzt jedes Mal wiederholen, wenn es einer nicht mitbekommen hat, dann wird es albern.
Wollen wir das einfach irgendwie URL auf die CCC-Seite packen oder so?
Guck doch mal, du hast doch da Internet oder nicht?
Ja, guck doch mal.
Und nicht du, ey. Na, du hast doch da Internet.
Soll ich die URL jetzt vorlesen oder wollen wir die einfach auf die CCC-Seite packen?
Ja, liest die URL mal vor.
Na gut, also URL ist berlin.ccc.de Schrägstrich, tilde, Tobias, Schrägstrich, sms-features.
Na komm, ein bisschen Arbeit muss Christian sich auch noch machen, damit er den Spaß hinterher genießen kann, okay?
Na, also da gibt's irgendwie einen Vortrag von mir, den ich halt mal gehalten hab auf dem letzten Chaos-Kongress, und da steht das unter anderem drin.
Christian, glücklich?
Alles klar, tschüss.
So, äh, hallo, Enrico.
Ja, du hast auch eine Frage?
Ja, genau, und zwar, ähm, habe ich einen 8210 Nokia, und wenn ich die Mitteilung auswähre im Menü, dann stürzt das Handy ab.
Also, wenn ich den Posteingang... Also, ich kann... In dem Menü von Kurzmitteilungseingang kriege ich noch, und wenn ich ihn auswähle, dann kriege ich ein leeres Display.
Es ist noch beleuchtet.
Und dann kann ich nur noch ausschalten.
Also, die Tasten müssen hier noch, die piepsen noch, aber ich kann nur noch ausschalten.
Und, ähm, ist das... Also, wenn du tatsächlich eine SMS auswählst, oder wie? Oder schon, wenn du den Kurzmitteilungseingang auswählst?
Wenn ich den Kurzmitteilungseingang auswähle...
Das heißt, du kannst dir keine einzige SMS mehr anzeigen lassen?
Äh, ja, das passiert schon mal bei Nokia-Telefonen. Also, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ist die Software breit, oder das Display an sich hat einen Fehler. Es gibt bei Nokia eine ganze Anzahl von Displayproblemen. Das äußert sich entweder dadurch, dass Displays teilweise aussetzen oder dass bei bestimmten Tastaturkombinationen die Displays einfach verschwinden und erst nach Neustart wieder angehen. Alternativ kann es, wie gesagt, auch die Software sein, da einfach mal ein Software-Update versuchen.
Also, ich habe das dann sozusagen mit dem Computer, mit dieser PC Suite die ganzen SMS sozusagen gelöscht, die da drauf waren, aber es ist immer noch vorhanden, also der Fehler. Es lag in der Lage, sie sind nicht an der letzten SMS, die irgendwie angekommen ist.
Wie alt ist denn das Telefon?
Das ist jetzt im Januar geholt.
Was hast du denn da für eine Softwareversion drauf?
Wie, ähm, von der PC Suite?
Nee, vom Telefon. Hast du das Telefon gerade da, oder?
Ja.
Gib dir mal ein Stern Raute, 4 mal die Null Raute.
Muss ich erst wieder einschalten.
Jetzt habe ich nämlich das Telefon gerade in das Telefon ausgeführt.
Und ist das, hast du sozusagen, wenn du, wenn das Telefon dann, hast du es schon mal mit einer anderen SIM-Karte versucht?
Nee.
Das könntest du nochmal versuchen? Und ja, ansonsten hilft wahrscheinlich wirklich bloß ein Software-Update.
Und was muss ich jetzt eingeben?
Stern Raute.
4 mal die Null.
Und dann?
Raute.
Wäre dann 529.
529 ist relativ aktuell. Eine 530 gibt es jetzt glaube ich noch.
Ja, aber dann haben sie nichts mehr geändert. Ja, nee, also dann versuch mal, versuch mal mit einer anderen SIM-Karte, also beziehungsweise dass du deine SIM-Karte mal in ein anderes Telefon tust. Und da mal die SMS, da mal guckst, ob noch SMS drauf sind. Und wenn ja, die löschen. Ansonsten halt mal die, eine andere SIM-Karte in das Telefon tun und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert. Und wenn das alles nicht hilft, dann, also du hast ja noch Garantie drauf, du kannst einfach zu einem Nokia Shop gehen, zum Nokia Service Center, dass sie dir da ein Software-Update drauf machen. Auch wenn das wieder die gleiche Software-Version ist, aber dass du halt die Software nochmal neu da drauf kriegst und dann funktioniert es wieder.
Und wo ist denn Berlin in so einem Center?
Wo wohnst du denn in Berlin?
Mitte.
In Mitte kannst du zum Beispiel Frankfurter Allee gehen. Da sind zwei, drei Telefon-Läden, die machen Service, soweit ich weiß.
Ansonsten kannst du auch bei Nokia.de klicken und da gibt es einen Link Service oder Händler.
Ich glaube, da landest du dann aber in Berlin automatisch bei Bluetail. Das möchte man nicht, oder?
Ja, Bluetail macht halt... Manchmal kriegen sie ein Softwareupdate schon hin. Bei Live nicht immer, aber manchmal kriegen sie das schon hin.
Enrico, viel Glück. Viel Glück oder kauf dir einen Siemens, habe ich gemacht.
Ich habe vorher einen Motorola gehabt.
Das ist doch immer schonmal ein Aufstieg.
Da kann man immerhin Nägel in die Wand kloppen, das kannst du mit keinem anderen Handy machen.
Ansonsten können wir vielleicht auch recherchieren, wo man Softwareupdates bekommt, und da vielleicht einen Link auf die Fritz-Seiten machen.
Ja, mit Sicherheit. Okay, Enrico, danke für deinen Anruf. Handyspiele, geh fort. Chaosradio 71, es geht um Handys unter www.fritz.de slash computer, da könnt ihr jetzt mal nachlesen, was ihr tun könnt, falls ihr Probleme mit der Software eures Siemens oder Nokia-Handys habt. Wir haben nämlich einen Laden gefunden, die tatsächlich, es ist unglaublich, die tatsächlich ein kostenloses Software-Update durchführen. Also selbst wenn ihr das Handy nicht da gekauft habt in dem Laden und die Garantie schon abgelaufen sein sollte, geht trotzdem hin, ihr kriegt ein Software-Update gemacht. Das ist dann nicht so wie bei Bluetel, wo man anruft und sagt, ich habe so Probleme mit meinem Nokia. Ja, 115 Mark.
Außerdem ist ein Kratzer auf dem Display, das geht leider nicht.
Was ist denn dann eigentlich mit meinen Telefonnummern? Sind die dann weg? Ja, die sind dann weg. Könnt ihr die dann irgendwie zwischenspeichern?
Ja, kostet nochmal 15 Mark.
Also unter www.fritz.de slash computer, da seht ihr, wie man es auch machen kann. Wo waren wir eigentlich stehen geblieben? Wir waren immer noch bei Abkürzungen. Habt ihr eigentlich schon mit Imode gespielt? Ich habe mir ja so ein Imode-Handy besorgt.
Also rumgespielt habe ich schon ein bisschen durst. Was heißt, du hast dir eins besorgt?
Ich habe bei E plus angerufen, habe gesagt, ich würde das ganz gerne mal testweise, also leihweise, haben so ein Gerät, um hinterher drüber zu reden. Und dann haben die mir eins geschickt. Dann habe ich mit rumgespielt.
Dann hast du also das zweite Gerät, was in Deutschland schon von Imkunde ist.
Nein, das hat der andere Kollege aus der Redaktion auch.
Und wie war deine Experience?
Das Gerät selber finde ich irgendwie ganz cool, weil das hat so etwas extrem Japanisches.
Das ist so ein sehr hochwertigen Eindruck.
Ja, aber die ganze Haptik ist unglaublich japanisch. Ich war da noch nie. Ich bilde mir ein, dass die ganze Haptik japanisch ist. Ich fand das nicht... Also das Handy ist ein Haufen Müll im Prinzip. Das Display ist mir viel zu klein. Also wenn die so ein riesen Deckel machen, dann können die da ein größeres Display rein machen.
Die Tasten sind auch zu klein.
Die haben einen miesen Druckpunkt.
Ja, also die stehen nicht hervor.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist komplett plan.
Ich hatte da meine Probleme mit. Das sind natürlich nur die Details.
Aber es flucht so richtig schön zu, wenn man es so zusammenklappt.
Es ist wirklich... Es fühlt sich sehr, sehr gut an. Aber das Hauptding ist einfach mal der Akku. Also du machst nichts mit dem Teil. Vielleicht 5 Minuten Telefone, der Akku ist in 2 Tagen leer, weil die dermaßen Stromverbrauch haben. Und wenn du anfängst zu surfen, was das Tolle ist, wenn du so ein Testgerät kriegst, dann zahlt E plus ja auch die Gebühren dazu. Da habe ich mir gedacht, ja guck, du guckst im Bad. Über Ostern saß ich so rum bei meinen Eltern, habe gehört, du surfst ein bisschen mit dem Handy in der Gegend rum. Und dann ist der Akku in 2 Stunden platt. Aber so richtig platt. Also es ist irgendwie nicht wirklich der Hit. Ansonsten fand ich es irgendwie ganz cool. Also ich fand es ganz okay, mal die Süddeutsche lesen zu können auf dem Ding. Und was wirklich total klasse ist, da ist ein Borghaus drin. Da kannst du dann immer nachgucken, wenn du irgendwie was nicht weißt. Das hatte ich tatsächlich. So habe ich Zeitungen gelesen, da dachte ich, was heißt das denn? Der Borghaus, ja.
Ist wo drin?
Naja, auf diesem E plus Einmol-Portal. Das ist schon eben hinten. Wobei, es ist brutal teuer. Also im Moment wollen sie noch 0, 1 Cent fürs K haben.
Genau, und demnächst 1 Cent.
1 Cent fürs K. Und das ist einfach mal brutal.
Und vor allen Dingen, da sind ja noch nicht die ganzen Gebühren für die Dienste drin.
Ja klar, du musst dann noch mal ein Abo zahlen. Also wenn du Spiegel Online überhaupt mal lesen willst, musst du schon mal 2 Euro im Monat abdrücken.
Aber ich meine, wenn man sich das sonst mal so anguckt, so im Gegensatz zu Wapp, ist das eigentlich, wenn man jetzt mal von den Kosten absieht, schon deutlich eher so, wie man das haben will. Da könnte man sich schon vorstellen, dass auch mit der Mail funktioniert einigermaßen und so. Und da könnte man sich schon vorstellen, dass das irgendjemand benutzt. Benutzt das eigentlich irgendjemand?
Wie die Kosten in Japan eigentlich von Imode? Wie die Kosten in Japan liegen von Imode? Weil da benutzt das ja wohl jeder.
Die sind ja auch ganz andere Falle gewöhnt.
Ich weiß es nicht. Du meinst, wer für ein Bier 12 Mark zahlt, zahlt auch für ein Kilowatt 10, wenn nicht?
Wer Kaffee durchbenutzt, das Schlüpferlfiltert.
Ich glaube, das sind Vorurteile.
Chaosradio 71, wir müssen an dieser Stelle mal kurz vom Thema abschweifen. Wir waren ja gerade bei Vorurteilen Japan betreffend. Da gibt es ja diese Legende, dass man in Japan den Automaten benutzt und Schlüpfer ziehen kann und der Ingenieur heute Abend, der Ingenieur der weiße Details, würdest du die bitte noch mal eben. Jetzt sag's schon!
Du sagst es jetzt!
Ihr habt es auch alle gehört.
Du sag es, sonst sage ich allen deinen Namen.
Es gibt aber so Automaten, wo man sich so benutzte Schlüpfer ziehen kann, die serienmäßig in Thailand hergestellt werden und mit Thunfisch-Extrakt beträufelt werden, damit sie authentisch sind.
So wir haben uns beruhigt.
Verzeihen. Hier ist Chaosradio 71, wir reden eigentlich über Handys. Was wolltest du wissen, Tobias? Ob ich mir diese...
Genau, die Tittenseiten.
Die schmutzigen Angebote in Imode angucke. Natürlich, ich hatte doch E plus bezahlt. Das ist ja das Albernste überhaupt. Also weil das hat eine eher suboptimal dargestellte Grafik. Also es sieht furchtbar aus. Es sieht wirklich aus, als hättest du mit Fingerfarben irgendwo hingemalt.
Dann kennst du noch Cementa Fox Tripp-Poker auf dem C64 in 60 Farben.
Genau, genau, genau. Was ich aber wirklich total...
Das hast du jetzt auch auf deinem Handy, oder? Wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Ja genau, es gibt einen großartigen C64-Emulator für den 9210 von Nokia. Darauf läuft sogar Giant Assisters.
Ich hab sogar das Tripp-Poker nicht gekauft, wie dieses Telefon.
Ja super, 2000 Mark.
Das ist auch der einzige Anwendungszweck.
Das ist der teuerste C64 in der Zelle sein.
Das hat dir früher auch gekostet.
Ne, 1300 ohne Peripherie.
Genau. Und außerdem war er nicht so klein. Guck mal, wie schön klein das jetzt ist.
Ja klar, deswegen kann man ja auch heute den gleichen Preis dafür hinlegen.
Und du konntest nicht damit telefonieren.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Es gibt bestimmt auch irgendjemand, der damit telefoniert hat.
Hallo.
Aber was ich wirklich ganz spaßig fand an diesem Imode-Telefon ist, du kannst da natürlich auch Klingeltöne runterladen, die sind größtenteils Müll, aber der bellende Hund, der ist absolut original. Ich habe das Ding bei meinen Eltern ins Wohnzimmer gelegt, habe es angerufen und mein Vater ist fast wahnsinnig gewöhnt.
Was ist das für ein Köter hier draußen? Was auch noch echt klasse ist, ist dieses alte klingelnde Telefon.
Das habe ich gar nicht gefunden.
Das gibt es auch noch. Das hört sich auch noch richtig gut an. So als ob da so eine alte Metallklingel drin war.
Hat eigentlich außer mir noch jemand von euch ausprobiert?
Nein, ich habe es 5 Minuten versucht, dann war der Akku alle.
Ich habe da so ein bisschen rumgeklickt und überall kam so, wenn sie diese Seite aufrufen wollen, dann zahlen sie ab jetzt monatliche Abo-Gebühr, 50 Cent.
Das ist genau das gleiche, als wenn man mal wieder nach Porno sucht. Ich mache das von Zeit zu Zeit, um den aktuellen Stand abzufragen. Also als statistische Entwicklung.
Du bist ja auch Volkswirt, so als Hobby jetzt.
Genau, und da rennt man ja eigentlich auch in nichts anderes als bitte gebühren hier und bitte gebühren da. Aber es wird halt auch wirklich nur für Porno funktionieren. Da wird es eigentlich auch funktionieren. Was mit Porno nicht funktioniert, funktioniert auch sonst nicht. VHS hat nur funktioniert mit Porno, und DVD funktioniert nur mit Porno. Alles, was wir heute an modernen Technologien haben, muss erstmal die Porno-Hürde überspringen, und dann ist es irgendwie tauglich.
Erdbeck, aber Erdbeck und ABS?
Erklär mir doch mal, was SMS-Porno ist.
Na ja, es ist halt erotische Anbahnung. Das ist schon durchaus ein Thema.
Tim?
Ja?
Chaosradio 71 auf Fritz, wir machen ein paar Nachrichten und danach da geht es dann ans Telefonieren. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Fritz-Hotline und so auch die Hotline im Chaosradio Nummer 71.
In Fritz in Frankfurt oder? Dann 101, 5.
Eine nachher zwölf. Heute Nacht Wolken und da fällt gelegentlich etwas Regen raus. Das Ganze bei neun bis sechs Grad. Tagsüber gelegentlich Sonne bei 16 bis 19 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Henrich.
Die Anschaffung des Transportflugzeuges A400M hat erneut für eine E-Cla im Haushaltsausschuss gesorgt. Die Ausschussmitglieder warfen Verteidigungsminister Scharping vor, mit finanziellen Zusagen an die Partnerstaaten den Willen des Parlaments missachtet zu haben. Der grüne Haushaltsexperte Metzkopf forderte den Rücktritt Scharpings. Die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden haben ein weiteres mutmaßliches Mitglied der palästinensischen Islamistenorganisation Al-Tawid festgenommen. Der Verdächtige soll morgen dem Ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt werden. Die Gruppe steht im Verdacht, terroristische Anschläge vorbereitet zu haben. Das tschechische Parlament hat eine Streichung der Bennis-Dekrete und eine Eigentumsrückgabe an Sudetendeutsche abgelehnt. Mit großer Mehrheit verabschiedete es eine Resolution, in der die Verordnungen als Folge des Zweiten Weltkrieges bezeichnet werden. Die Entschließung war eine Reaktion auf Forderungen. Prag müsse vor einem EU-Beitritt die Dekrete streichen. Die katholische Kirche hat in den USA... Ne, will... Ich fange diese Meldung nochmal von vorne an. Die katholische Kirche in den USA will Priester nach schweren Fällen des Kindesmissbrauchs entlassen. Diesen Vorschlag machten führende US-Kardinäle zum Abschluss ihrer Krisengespräche im Vatikan an eine Aufhebung des Zürich-Barts ist nicht gedacht. Sportfußball im Halbfinale-Hinspiel der Champions League trennten sich Manchester United und Bayer Leverkusen 2 zu 2 unentschieden und Basketball im Playoff Vierte Finale Zweites Spiel gewann Alba Berlin gegen Bayer Leverkusen mit 92 zu 87. Perkett auf Fritz, keine Meldung, gute Fahrt.
Stars 2002. Cypress Hill, am 5. Mai in der Columbia-Halle Berlin.
Chaosradio 71 auf Fritz. Um Handys geht's. Und über Handys wollen wir auch mit euch reden, liebe Hörende.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Was redet man denn da so über Handys? Also mich würde ja zum Beispiel mal interessieren, ob irgendjemand I-Mode benutzt. Also ob das tatsächlich jemand benutzt und was auch immer.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Oder WAP.
WAP-Zahler benutzt tatsächlich jemand, WAP.
Stimmt, 0331, 70, 97, 110. Das ist die Nummer hier im Studio. Uns interessiert, ob ihr WAP benutzt beziehungsweise diese ganzen Features, die es da so gibt. Also da gibt es ja noch mehr so Zeugs.
Oder welche Features ihr gerne mehr hättet, was das immer noch nicht gibt.
Load a Game oder sowas in der Richtung.
Genau, und welches Feature ihr versucht zu benutzen, ob es denn funktioniert.
Wenn es nicht Nokia ist, funktioniert es, oder?
Wie war das?
Ach, es gibt ja noch andere Kandidaten.
Wie dem auch sei.
So, jetzt mal anrufen hier. 0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Was ist denn eigentlich mit UMTS?
Die unterwartete Mehreinnahme zur Tilgung von Staatsschulden.
Na, läuft ganz gut auf der Isle of Man, oder?
Ach genau, da haben die doch ein Testnetz. Läuft das wirklich?
Wohl ja.
Und wie groß ist das Telefon, dass die dafür... Also, ich meine, da gibt es ja noch gar keine Produkte, oder?
Na doch, es gibt halt so Produkte im Prototypen-Stadium. Dementsprechend funktioniert es halt auch. Also, die rebooten da halt noch mehrmals am Tag ihr Netz.
Du meinst die eine Zelle, oder?
Und die Telefone sowieso und so. Aber rein theoretisch funktioniert das wohl. Man hat halt irgendwie Datenübertragungsraten von 384 Kbit oder so.
Na, die Telefone rebooten die sich doch von selber.
Genau. Und wenn das halt gerade mal funktioniert, kann man da Live-Video-Stream drüber machen.
Ich meine, 2003 wollten die das hier einführen. Das werden die doch nie im Leben hinkriegen, oder?
Nee, nee, das haben die doch alles schon irgendwie so... Beziehungsweise 2003 sagen sie jetzt ja, soll funktionieren. Aber dann ist... Wie das halt so ist, GPHS haben sie auch irgendwann gesagt. So ab Sommer 2001 ist das... Ab Sommer 2000 haben sie alle behauptet, das gibt es jetzt. Und das kann man jetzt machen. Und dann konnte man halt keine Telefone kaufen. Und das hat nicht funktioniert. Und so wird das halt mit UMTS wahrscheinlich am Anfang auch sein.
Jetzt geht es gerade erst los mit GPHS eigentlich.
So, wo es jetzt Telefone gibt.
Das wird doch bestimmt noch zwei Jahre dauern bis UMTS. Aber es hat zumindest den Vorsprung des Mega-Hypes. Also es kann gut sein, aber es kann aber auch schlecht sein. Die Erwartungshaltung ist halt groß auf der anderen Seite. Man muss jetzt kaum noch Geld ausgeben, um den Leuten klar zu machen, was UMTS ist. Und zumindest glauben sie jetzt schon, es wäre irgendwas Tolles. Wir müssen halt nur noch ein bisschen Details nachliefern.
Ja, warten wir das mal ab. 0331 77 97 110. Wir reden über Handys und da reden wir hoffentlich mit euch drüber. Hallo Frank.
Ich habe gerade erst die Sendung angemacht, weil ich reingekommen bin von unterwegs. Sonst höre ich die immer regelmäßig. Und dann habe ich gerade gehört, dass ihr über WAP und Nokia euch ausgelassen habt.
Worüber sonst, ja.
Ich musste mir irgendwann mal ein neues Handy kaufen, weil bei dem Alten das Akku alle war und das ist dann immer so mit dem Generatron 6 verbunden.
Ich muss mir ein neues Handy kaufen, mein Akku ist alle. Das ist so wie, ich muss mir einen neuen Wagen kaufen.
Genau, der Aschenbecher ist voll.
Ich nehme an, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Genau.
So und da wollte ich ursprünglich auf GPRS und sowas alles aufsetzen und das war aber vor eben, ja, noch nicht so weit. Aber ich habe zumindest ein Nokia-Handy, was WAP kann. WAP 6210. Ich bin auch ganz zufrieden damit, nachdem ich mich dran gewöhnt habe. Ich hatte vorher immer Siemens und ja, dieses WAP nutze ich in erster Linie. Wenn ich mal irgendwo bin und eine E-Mail bekomme, dann bekomme ich also über eine SMS Bescheid, dass ich jetzt eine E-Mail habe. Wenn ich dann entscheide, jetzt will ich doch unbedingt wissen, was da drin steht, dann nutze ich die WAP-Funktion eigentlich zu nichts anderem. Und dafür finde ich die ganz sinnvoll.
Wie machst du das?
Wie mache ich das?
Welchen Dienstanbieter benutzt du dafür? Oder wie holst du deine E-Mail über WAP ab? Hast du das selber aufgesetzt oder benutzt du da irgendeinen Free-Mail-Service wie web.de?
Ich bin bei D2 und habe noch ein normales Postfach. Und habe aber zu diesem D2-Postfach eine Vorwartadresse gelegt. Und die bieten halt den Vorteil oder den Service an, dass du dich informieren, wenn du auf diesem Server eine Mail hast. Und dann kann ich mit diesem D2-Handy über diese WAP-Oberfläche von D2 da reingehen und mir auf dem Server meine E-Mails angucken.
Das ist doch sauteuer oder nicht?
Na gut, das WAP kostet irgendeinen Minutenpreis. Ich brauche höchstens zwei Minuten, um das zu lesen, was ich brauche. Das sind 60-Fan-Ic. Und das mache ich mindestens einmal oder zweimal im Monat. Also äußerst selten, nur wenn es wirklich ganz dringend ist. Wenn ich keinen Rechner in der Nähe habe. Und dazu, denke ich mal, ist das eine feine Sache. Wie ich das mache? Ich halte mich äußerst zurück, um mit meiner E-Mail-Adresse die weiterzugeben.
Ja, das ist gut.
Also du findest das toll.
Und wie viel zahlst du für eine SMS, dass du eine E-Mail erhalten hast?
Nichts.
Das ist kostenlos bei dir zwei?
Ja. Also die haben irgendwann gesagt, die richten jetzt einen Probebetrieb ein. Wir können das nutzen. Und seitdem weiß ich nicht, ob ich was bezahle. Also bis jetzt haben sie noch nichts gesagt, dass ich für die SMS was bezahle. Ich denke nicht.
Also ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass die, also du meinst, bis jetzt hat nichts auf der Rechnung gestanden, weil ich glaube nicht, dass die explizit sagen, ab jetzt kostet es Geld, oder?
Also es hat noch nichts auf der Rechnung gestanden und in dem Portal habe ich auch noch nichts gesehen, dass es ab jetzt Geld kostet.
Das ist ja gut, weil bei den anderen Netzbetreibern kostet es ja meistens den ganz normalen SMS-Preis. Genau. Und damit ist das dann schon ganz, wieder sofort total uninteressant.
Genau. Also das finde ich halt das Gute da, wo ich jetzt bin. Bei dem Provider, wo ich sonst bin, das ist so ein kleiner, feiner in Berlin, das NAFU nennt ja sich, da könnte ich das auch machen, dass ich direkt aufs Handy die Mitteilung bekomme. Das wurde aber was kosten. Die SMS. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich zu denen über WAP reinkomme. Aber hier, das mit dem D2 hat sich angeboten, das war so eine Komplettlösung.
Da braucht man nicht viel nachdenken.
Aber ich denke mal zu allen anderen Sachen, um da hier so wahnsinnig zu surfen, übers Telefon und so. Ich denke, das ist einfach Quatsch. Schon von einer Auflösung her und alles, von der Geschwindigkeit.
Was ich jetzt zum Beispiel bei Imode ganz cool fand, war, dass du da tatsächlich eine E-Mail kriegen und verschicken kannst. Auch nur mit 1000 Zeichen, was nicht unbedingt viel ist. Aber es funktioniert, du kannst tatsächlich echt E-Mail machen.
Das kann ich auch über dieses WAP-Portal.
Ja gut, aber die E-Mails kommen nicht bei dir im Handy an. Das fand ich irgendwie das Interessante, dass du deine E-Mails im Handy hast, wie du sie zu Hause auf dem Rechner möglicherweise hast.
Interessant. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie viele E-Mails du so bekommst, aber bei mir könnte ich ja jeden Tag ein neues Handy kaufen.
Das wäre teuer, das stimmt.
Bei mir hältst du dich den Grenzen.
Allein die E-Mails, die mich dazu auffordern, um meinen Penis zu vergrößern, sind einige Hunderte im Monat. Frank, danke für deinen Anruf.
Danke dir auch.
Hallo Raul.
Ja, du benutzt auch WAP?
Ja, ohne Ende.
Ohne Ende?
Für was?
Ich chatte meistens.
Du chattest per WAP?
Ja, natürlich. Da gibt es einen richtig abgefahrenen Chatraum, das geht über Web3. Und ja, da sind auch ziemlich viele Stammchatter und das ist richtig abgefahren. Da sind schon ein paar Lustige dabei.
Machst du das über GPRS oder über eine Webverbindung?
Das geht über ein GPRS. Richtig günstig ist es natürlich, wenn man via Kineon hinterkommt, also von der Homezone das macht, dann ist es genauso schnell wie ein Rechner und es ist einfach kleiner und der Chatraum ist richtig geil und da chatte ich öfters dran.
Hast du denn da so eine kleine Tastatur dran oder machst du das alles über...?
Ich habe einen Siemens, dieses S49 und das hat eine sehr coole T9-Eingabe und das geht rasend schnell, zazazazack und dann tippt man den Mist ein und dann geht's raus.
Was hast du nur so für eine Rechnung im Monat?
Das ist gar nicht viel. Ich meine, wenn man über VIRC, also Hygienion reingeht, dann ist es drei Fenich pro Minute, das ist ja ein Witz.
Moment, pro Minute? Wieso, wenn du über G-Pair S reingehst, dann zahlst du ja nicht pro Minute, sondern zahlst ja den Traffic, also pro Byte sozusagen.
Du hast einmal die Verbindung, einmalig, und dann hast du die G-Pair S-Cost. Aber das ist lächerlich. Pro Einheit, pro Package, da zahlst du nicht viel. Das ist super wenig.
Also du zahlst ja bei VIRC pro 10 Kilobyte Block immer...
Sag mal Raul, hast du das Radio an?
Ja, aber nur ganz leise.
Dann machst du es bitte ganz aus.
Ja, das ist nicht viel. Ab und zu funktioniert das mit der G-Pair S-Verbindung nicht. Dann geht man normal über die CSD rein, also über die normale Verbindung. Und dann ist es auch gut. Ich nutze es auch für andere Sachen, also auch für E-Mails. Da kriege ich leider keine Nachricht. Aber da gehe ich so rein, aber das ist auch ganz okay. Ich finde es total praktisch. Oder wenn ich einen Kinokarten reservieren soll, über Cinemax kann ich auch sofort reingehen, ich kann mir zwei Karten reservieren und habe die Nummer usw. Dann brauche ich nicht zu telefonieren und so. Das finde ich richtig cool. Also es ist schon ganz gut gemacht. Und dieses Imode, ich weiß nicht, ob das spektakulär ist, das ist ein bisschen mit Farbe und blablabla, das ist eigentlich ein Witz, weil wenn hinterher jetzt dieses neue System rauskommt, wo man auch Fernsehen drüber gucken kann usw. das wird etwas interessanter. Aber das Imode ist ja nichts anderes, als das wir jetzt haben, bloß mit Farbe drauf. Ja, meine Meinung ist...
Alles nickt mit dem Kopf. Alles nickt mit dem Kopf. Wo ist dieser Chat-Server? Wo klingst du dich da ein zum Chatten?
Also eigentlich geht das chat.web3.net. Und dann kommt man rein auf diese Seite. Und die ist ziemlich cool. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist ziemlich geil. Da kommt schon ein abgedrehtes Freak da immer rein.
Ja klar, wer mit dem Handy chattet. Also jetzt nichts gegen dich.
Ich bin gerade auf Toilette, man hat keine Zeitung zur Hand.
Geht man in den Chatraum rein, und dann fließt das einfach. Also wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze und gerade keine Zeitung hab, dann mach ich eben irgendwie wabtagesschau.de oder sowas. Nein, das ging mir jetzt nicht um.
Nein, lasst mich nicht.
Ich brauchte jetzt keine Stimulation. Ich brauchte Information. Das dachte ich.
Stimulation, das ist jetzt groß und groß.
Bei diesem Sat.3 Chat soll ich ja mal reingehen. Das sind total abgedrehte Freaks. Die haben auch schon mal ein Chat treffen gemacht. Und das sind so ganz, ganz komische Füße dabei.
Alles klar, Raul, vielen Dank.
Okay, bis dann, Jungs.
Null, drei, drei, eins, 70, 97, eins, eins, null. Erzählt uns, was ihr für Probleme mit euren Handys habt. Möglicherweise wissen wir eine Lösung. Wenn wir keine wissen, dann lachen wir gemeinsam mit euch. Null, drei, drei, eins, 70, 97, eins, eins, null. Die Fritz-Hotline und auch die Hotline natürlich hier im Chaosradio 71. Hallo, Matthias. Matthias? Du hast die Endlösung für E-Mails?
Ja klar, ich hab die absolut. Ich bin irgendwie, außer ein Technik-Fittischist, werde ich zumindest beschimpft. Und ich musste mir eine Lösung überlegen, wie ich eben halt über Ortsnetzwahl hier mir meine E-Mails abrufen kann. War sogar mal bei FIAC für eben halt den Ortstarif möglich pro Minute. Und ja, das funktioniert. Einwandfrei.
Das hab ich nicht kapiert.
Dass ich meine E-Mails per Handy verschicke und empfangen kann. Überwappen. Ich hab da hier Business-Handy, also nicht das Nokia, sondern eben halt andere große Führer, hier Siemens, und hab mir da dieses Ding dazu gekauft, diesen IC35. Da ist SMTP und ein POP3-Server-Möglichkeit drin. Und da verschicke ich dann eben halt über Infra-Roti-Dinger hin und her.
Du benutzt sozusagen das Handy quasi als Modem zu deinem Organizer.
Ja, genau das.
Wobei es aber auch ziemlich teuer wird, sobald du mal irgendwie am Tag 20, 30 Mails machen musst.
Das ist echt okay, weil für das Meiste, das dauert echt die Einwahl. Die dauert eine Minute. Und nach einer Minute gehen die einzelnen Mails recht schnell durch. Also für 30 Mails bräuchte ich vielleicht 5 Minuten.
Und hast du schon mal nachgerechnet, ob das über Einwahl oder über GPRS billiger wäre?
Nee, das habe ich noch nicht nachgerechnet. Also ich habe da auch einen Vertrag, der diese City da beinhaltet und der mitswandert, ohne dass ich Grundgebühr bezahle. Und von daher zahle ich in jeder Stadt, wo ich eben halt meine 15 Pfennig bin. Und das ist also nicht viel für eben halt die Menge, die ich an E-Mails durchbekomme. Und das Gute ist daran, dass man eben halt durch die Einstellung des POP3-Servers da auch in jeder Stadt eben halt z.B. von Yahoo oder von GMX seine Mails runtersaugen kann, solange die unter 4 Kilo weit sind. Also diese eine Begrenzung gibt es ja doch.
Du kannst keine Mails dir unter 4K, über 4K kannst du eine Mails...
Also ich habe auch unter meinen Mails drunter stehen, dass die eben halt reine Textnachrichten schicken sollen, ohne Bilder, ohne HTML-Tanzierungen und 4K sind 4 DIN-A-4 Seiten. Das ist vollkommen okay.
Ja, ja, stimmt.
Ja, also und die großen, also du hast gerade selber gesagt, diese Spun-Mails oder so, die ja meistens wesentlich größer sind, die will ich ja gar nicht auf dem kleinen Ding haben. Weißt du, die ergeht dann nochmal einmal, wenn ich in den Internet-Shop gegangen bin, als ich noch kein Internet zu Hause habe und hab da eben halt die Dinger dann gelöscht, weil die störenden beim Runtersaugen, dann sagt er immer, Mail über 4K, aber das war's dann auch.
Das ist eigentlich ein guter Trick. Die ganzen Spams, die haben ja so viel Code immer noch mit drin. Ja, stimmt, guter Trick.
Ich find das immer toll, wenn das irgendwie bei den Leuten so geht. Also bei mir ist das anders.
Tim, was ist denn?
Ich krieg einfach, weiß nicht, Megabyteweise kommt diese Kacke.
Ja, wieso die Kacke? Also das geht eben halt um die Organisation der E-Mail-Adressen. Ich hab auch eine E-Mail-Adresse, wo eben halt riesige Mails ankommen können. Aber das wissen die Leute dann. Also wenn sie mir große Sachen schicken, dann geht das eben nach dahin und nicht auf den Server, den ich eh für meine normalen Textnachrichten benutze. Da kann man viel verschiedene Sachen einstellen. Und von daher hat es eben auch die Möglichkeit, da sehr flexibel umzugehen.
Der Trend geht zu Zweit-E-Mail.
Ja, natürlich. Ein Kumpel von mir, ein total abgedrehter in New York, ist da jetzt mittlerweile, der hat 50 E-Mail-Adressen. Der schickt mir immer seine neue, aber er sagt, ich schick mir da bloß nix hin. Die sind alle bloß weitergeleitet, benutzt die alte.
Ja, da gab es doch irgendwie Mitte der 90er, da gab es noch mal so diesen Forward-Boom.
Ja, richtig, der kommt ja auch raus.
Genau, und dann at whitehouse.com. Ja, genau.
Oder wer hat zu Wudel kommen oder so.
Ach, das gab es auch.
Ja klar, hat er auch mal.
Davon sowas kenne ich ja nix.
Wie war das denn gerade von euch, der da auch ab und an up to date bleiben muss?
Wie war denn das? Keiner meldet sich in diesem Sinne eine gute Nacht, Mathias.
Ja, wirklich, ich auch. Und mach so weiter. Noch zwei Sachen wollte ich sagen. Warum benutzt ihr den IRC-Chat Fritz nicht? Also, dass ihr da nicht mal reinguckt. Und zum zweiten eure Webcam, die steht ja absolut im Himmel.
Das ist richtig. Das liegt daran, dass unser Ingenieur unerkannt bleiben will, aus naheliegenden Gründen, weil er nämlich relativ eng mit der Telefonindustrie verwandelt ist. Wir drehen das Ding jetzt mal auf Tim. Wir drehen das jetzt mal auf Tim. Und das mit dem Chat, das kann ich dir relativ simpel erklären. Das liegt daran, dass du kannst entweder senden oder chatten, sobald du deine Aufmerksamkeit im Chat mitmirst, bist du komplett von der Sendung weg. Das ist immer etwas unangenehm und darum meiden wir das.
Aber vielleicht benutzen ja nette Praktikanten mit trinken Fingern dann den Chat.
Die müssen um diese Zeit ins Bett. Die müssen ja morgen wieder Kaffee kochen, morgen früh, ein Brötchen schmieren.
Ich hätte ja hier liebend gerne Internet.
Matthias, gute Nacht.
Ich hätte ja so gerne Internet.
Natürlich hättest du das gerne. Chaosradio 71 und falls ihr nicht glauben wollt, dass es möglich ist, einen C64-Immulator auf dem Nokia Communicator zu haben, jetzt schnell www.fritz.de und die Webcam anklicken, weil wir haben mal versucht dieses Bild irgendwie da drauf zu laden. Wir reden immer noch über Handys, möglicherweise hat der ein oder andere ja auch die ein oder andere technische Frage zu seinem Gerät, also warum geht das nicht oder wie geht das eigentlich? Auch dann seid ihr hier herzlich willkommen unter 0331 70 97 110. Hallo Martin.
Also ich habe ich habe das mit dem Motorola Tastensperren-Bug ausprobiert bei meinem Timeport 250.
Können wir noch mal kurz für alle die gerade erst zugeschaltet haben, wie der Bug ging?
Ja irgendwie wenn man da ein SMS, also wenn die Tastensperre angeschaltet ist und man ein SMS empfängt, dann soll es irgendwie die SMS auf Nimmerwiedersehen verschwinden oder wie?
Nein, sie verschwindet nicht auf Nimmerwiedersehen, aber das Telefon fragt in dem Augenblick SMS eingetroffen Lesen und wenn man dann auf OK drückt um die SMS zu lesen, sagt das Telefon nur noch Tastensperre aktiv, bitte Tastensperre rausnehmen und in dem Augenblick ist die SMS ins Untermenü verschwunden, war zumindest. Zumindest bei Motorola, solange ich denken kann, das Problem beim 930, bei TimePod 7389 war es der Fall, bei weiteren TimePods wohl auch. Ist es bei dem TimePod jetzt auch noch der Fall oder haben sie es endlich in den Griff gekriegt?
Nein, ich glaube jetzt ist es nicht mehr, warte mal, ich schicke mal schnell eins, Moment, ich soll ja gleich kommen.
Ah, der Trend geht zum Zweithandy.
Wenn es funktionieren würde, dann hätte ich auch eins.
Also es ist vor allem das passiert, es steht immer noch WISC-GSM, Tastensperre, und oben ist das das Icon für eingegangene Meldungen, also das Q-Ware.
Genau, und auf dem Display müsst ihr jetzt stehen, sie haben eine neue SMS.
Nein, das tut es nicht, es steht nur Tastensperre.
Und wenn du jetzt die Tastensperre rausnimmst, dann hast du aber nicht direkt auf dem Bildschirm eine Meldung, oder?
Nein, da steht Nachricht, jetzt lesen und dann kann ich ja OK drücken und dann zeigst du mir die SMS erst an.
Ein Wunder, sie haben es geschafft, nach fünf Jahren.
Sag mal, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Zürich.
Und wie hörst du uns?
Über Astra. Satellit kommt hier in Stereo an, wunderbar. Ich hätte noch eine zweite Frage und zwar ihr habt das Thema irgendwie noch nicht angeschnitten und zwar Cell-Broadcast. Hier in der Schweiz bei Swisscom gibt es so eine Art Killer-Feature, wenn man da Kanal 50 einstellt, dann sieht man, in welcher Zelle man angelockt ist. Zum Beispiel steht bei mir jetzt Zürich Nordwest. Und in Deutschland habe ich schon festgestellt, da wird zum Teil Werbung geschickt. Ich glaube es war D2 und zwar D1 oder D2, Kanal 123. Da stand dann plötzlich so Zeug, so jetzt Aktion, Tisch, Ventilatoren für 10 D-Mark, Start 129 und dann Telefonnummer 0190 und so weiter. An und für sich ist das ja Spam, aber auf dem Time-Pod scrollt das dann einfach so durch und das fand ich ganz witzig. Jetzt wollte ich fragen, gibt es da noch mehr Kanäle oder wisst ihr da irgendwas?
Also in Deutschland ist das nie so richtig benutzt worden. Es gab halt immer wieder Versuche und es gab zur CeBIT immer mal irgendwelche Trials. Das ist aber nie, insbesondere weil das 6150 hatte mal so einen hässlichen Bug, dass das komplett abgestürzt ist beim Empfang von CeBIT. Deshalb ist das nie so richtig benutzt worden. Wer das inzwischen richtig benutzt, ist Viagra Intercom, oder wie das jetzt heißt, O2 in Deutschland. Die benutzen das, um die Anzeige deiner City bzw. Homezone zu machen. Wir haben ja dieses Feature, dass du in deiner Homezone bist, und dann zahlst du nur Ortstarif, wenn du telefonierst, von deinem Handy aus. Das wird angezeigt im Display. Und das funktioniert so, dass Cell-Broadcast-Nachrichten auf Kanal 221 versendet werden, in denen die Koordinaten der Zelle, in die du gerade eingebucht bist, im Gauss-Krüger-Koordinatenformat drinstehen. Und das Handy, bzw. die SIM-Karte hat den Radius gespeichert, innerhalb dessen die Koordinaten liegen müssen, damit du in deiner Home- in deiner Cityzone bist. Und das ist also der Nutzen, den es davon gibt. Das heißt, wenn man in 4-Hack eingebucht ist, kann man relativ leicht feststellen, wo man gerade ist. Auch ohne GPS ist es natürlich nur immer auf die nächste Zelle genau, aber das funktioniert einigermaßen.
Ja, wobei ich habe schon festgestellt in Zürich, bei der Swisscom, dass es plötzlich ändert, auch wenn das Handy einfach so auf dem Tisch liegt und sich nicht bewegt, zwischendurch stand da Zürich City und dann Erlikon, das ist da so ein anderer Stadtteil, dass es sich einfach umgebucht hat.
Ja, dass es nichts Unnormales ist, das passiert halt irgendwie, dass plötzlich das Telefon die eine Zelle stärker empfängt als die andere. Manchmal ist es halt nur so ein, zwei dB Unterschied und dann ändert sich das aufgrund von geänderten Wetterverhältnissen.
Oder von der Natur parken LKW.
Genau, so etwas hat er alles. Oder wenn jemand gerade vor deinem Handy läuft, hat er alles Einfluss drauf.
Ich würde ja auch gerne mal so einen Cell-Broadcast sehen. Was muss ich da machen hier mit meinem Handy? Siemens ME45.
Wenn du das nächste Mal in der Schweiz seid, wähl doch bei Swisscom ein. Und dann Kanal 50 ist das. Je nachdem, wo man ist. Wenn ihr in den Flughafen Zürich ankommt, steht da Zürich Airport.
Aber das braucht auch noch eine ganze Menge Strom, diese Funktion, oder?
Egal. Wenn es ändert, scrollt es zumindest beim Timeport durch. Und dann bleibt es stehen auf den ersten zehn Zeichen.
Also es braucht nicht mehr so viel Strom. Früher war das mal irgendwie schlimmer, aber jetzt ist es nicht mehr so auffällig. Was noch ganz interessant ist, ich glaube, in Litauen war das. Hat mir mal jemand erzählt, der da war, in der Hauptstadt. Wie heißt denn die Hauptstadt? Weißte jemand? Genau. Da ist es... Genau, richtig. Wollte ich gerade sagen.
Ja, wissen wir doch alle.
Genau.
Da ist es wohl so, die haben da eine unglaubliche Dichte an GSM-Zellen. Und da ist es tatsächlich so, dass man mit Cellbroadcast die aktuelle Straße und Hausnummer angezeigt kriegt, vor der man gerade steht. Also nicht tatsächlich so vor Nummer 23 jetzt, sondern so ein Hausnummer in Range, irgendwie zwischen 1 und 50 oder so was. Aber es ist tatsächlich so genau, dass man immer weiß, in welcher Straße man gerade ist und total unglaublich.
Ob ich das in Litauen haben will?
Letztes Jahr hatten sie es an der Orbit in Basel. Am letzten Tag haben sie es hingekriegt, dass in der Halle stand auf dem Handy Orbit. Draußen stand dann Basel Zentrum. Es war lediglich am letzten Tag, haben sie das aktiv geschaltet.
Das ist wirklich verblüffend, dass es in Deutschland nicht so weit verbreitet ist, weil es ist ja wirklich das perfekte Werbeinstrument.
Das mag es schon auch mit dem Tod dieses einen Handys viel zu tun gehabt haben. Das war doch auch gerade auf der CeBit, als das hier losging. Auf der CeBit wollten sie es halt demonstrieren und alle liefen halt mit ihren 62.50. 71.50, was halt auch das verbreitetste Phon war von Nokia. Und sie haben halt sozusagen alle Telefone kaputt gemacht. Das übertrieben dargestellt auf der CeBit. So einfach mal, wir fangen an zu senden und auf einmal konnten halt alle nicht mehr telefonieren, was natürlich ein echter Gau war.
Bei Cell-Broadcast ist da glaube ich eh eine Begrenzung auf 93 Zeichen oder so.
Ja, es gibt eine Begrenzung. Es ist nicht so lang wie SMS. Ich habe es jetzt gerade nicht genau im Kopf, aber das ist auf jeden Fall noch weniger. Aber es ist halt so die Frage bei Werbung, ob sich das wirklich richtig lohnen würde, weil du kannst nicht feststellen, wem das jetzt alles erreicht hat und kannst es nicht zielgruppenmäßig machen. Du kannst es bloß auf eine Stadt begrenzen oder so was.
03317797110.
Was?
Lettland?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, ob es Litauen oder Lettland war.
Wie ist denn die Hauptshot von Lettland?
Riga.
Es war Lettland.
Guten Abend Andreas.
Hallöchen. Du willst jetzt nicht in unseren Chor mit einstimmen?
Also meine einzige und erste Erfahrung mit WAP war mal in Frankfurt am Main. Ich wollte mal früher mit dem Zug fahren, habe mich ins WAP-Portal der Deutschen Bahn eingewählt. Und die erste Aktion, die natürlich kam, war Server überlastet.
Ja, das ist natürlich dann doof. Bei mir hat das in Frankfurt am Main wunderbar funktioniert.
Ja, weiß nicht, war eine Messezeit und vielleicht wollten alle irgendwie schnell weg. Also WAP und E-Mail und so weiter, ich weiß nicht, dafür ist WAP irgendwie zu langsam, zu unschön und da E-Mails zu lesen, gerade wenn irgendwelche HTML-E-Mails ankommen, dafür ist WAP einfach ungeeignet, finde ich. Also lieber eine gute Hscsd-Verbindung. Also ich persönlich habe ich auch damals noch einen 9110 gehabt, was ich wesentlich besser von der Bedienung fand als das 9210, was ich jetzt habe. Und da klappt da einfach mal ein bisschen so Internet, einfache Seiten aufrufen, Informationen holen, E-Mails abrufen, wunderbar.
Hscsd ist sowieso eigentlich eine schöne Sache. Es wird natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr beworben von den Netzbetreibern jetzt, weil sie jetzt alle GPRS verkaufen wollen.
Kannst du es vielleicht mal kurz erläutern, was sich dahinter verbirgt?
Hinter Hscsd?
Tobias kurz?
Hscsd steht für High-Speed-Circuit-Switched-Data und ist sozusagen eine ganz normale W-Verbindung, aber nicht wie beim normalen CSD, wie halt die ganz normale, langsame 9600 Bit pro Sekunde GSM-W-Verbindung ist, sondern eine Verbindung, wo du halt mehrere Kanäle zusammenbündelst. Und dann halt die gebündelte Geschwindigkeit nutzen kannst, bis zu 43, 2 Kilobit die Sekunde. Und ja, das funktioniert halt, also in Deutschland haben das D2 und E+. Das funktioniert zuverlässig inzwischen. Es gibt da sehr attraktive Tarife, die alles mit GPRS um Längen in den Schatten stellen. Also sobald man irgendwie was anderes macht, außer irgendwie jede Stunde mal eine E-Mail zu empfangen oder zu schreiben, ist Hscsd einfach deutlich günstiger. Da hat man natürlich wieder die Sache mit der Einwahl und dass man nicht allways online ist. Aber das ist eigentlich echt eine recht günstige Sache. Und 43, 2 Kilobit, das reicht schon ungefähr an, irgendwie heutige Analog-Modems ran.
Da musst du aber auch sagen, du kommst auf andere, in welcher Gegend du bist. In Berlin kriegst du halt nur einfach zwei Abkanäle, also Hscsd, so wie ich es kenne, ist halt einfach eine 28-Achter-Verbindung. Zwei Kanäle ab, zwei Kanäle down. In Mannheim hab ich es mal erlebt, da hatte ich mal drei Kanäle ab und ein Kanal, äh, quatsch, drei Kanäle down zum Handy und ein Kanal ab, das war natürlich nett, aber ansonsten eigentlich, sei mal, eine 28-Achter-Modem-Verbindung, würde ich sagen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich hab auch deutlich schnellere Verbindungen in Berlin gehabt.
Hm, wer weiß von welchem Provider du deine Karte hast?
E plus.
Ja, kann sein, also Standard D2, oder ich hab eine Hatchensynkarte, also Berlin, eigentlich 28-Achter, und bei mir auf dem Haus, also gegen von der Firma, ist eine Funkzelle, aber ich krieg eh nicht mehr. Ich sitze allerdings auch am Alex mit der Firma, vielleicht ist da doch ein bisschen viel Traffic.
Wo man dann noch dazusagen muss, irgendwie GPAS, ist zurzeit meistens auch nicht deutlich schneller als 28-Achter.
Das hab ich heute erlebt, weil ich so für Fernwirkübertragungen, also für den Gasölbereich, so Fernwirkstationen, die irgendwo in der Wallachei stehen, so mit GPAS, wo da irgendwie jede Stunde so zwei, drei Daten anfallen und die übertragen werden müssen, da mal irgendwie eine Standstrecke zu bekommen, ist einfach zurzeit abenteuerlich.
Das ist aber genau der Anwendungsbereich, wo das dann Sinn macht. Also zurzeit funktioniert das noch nicht so richtig, aber genau dafür wird das halt Sinn machen. Da gibt es ja auch jetzt so schöne Module, halt so, was ich Siemens MC35 oder so, was man sich da kaufen kann. Das hat halt GPRS drin, da steckt man eine SIM-Karte rein und dann nach der Theorie klebt man das halt irgendwo hin, versorgt es mit Strom und dann hat das halt immer ein Netz. Aber mit dem so richtig always online, ist das leider noch nicht so weit her.
Ja, es ist vor allen Dingen schön, wenn gerade wie jetzt wieder so eine schöne, schlechte Atterperiode ist. Und wenn die ganzen Empfangsgebiete nicht so richtig abgedeckt sind. Also ich habe es heute Morgen erlebt auf einer Kundenanlage. Und da sieht man so schön, so rot für keine Verbindung. Ach, da ist die Antenne ein bisschen schwach. Na ja, gut, dass die Station noch die Daten noch mal über 24 Stunden sammelt.
Also da gibt es auch noch was, was ich jetzt in der letzten Zeit häufig festgestellt habe. Also ich probiere sehr viel mit GPRS rum. Und es kommt einfach mal vor, keine Ahnung, also bei D1 und 4G hatte ich das letztlich so. Bei 4G war neulich einfach mal GPRS für den ganzen Tag aus. So, ging halt einfach mal gar nicht. Und D1 neulich auch, neulich den ganzen Abend, so mehrere Stunden lang, ging halt nicht, war einfach nicht da. Und die Telefon zeigt das ja an, ob es GPRS gibt, aber es war halt einfach überhaupt gar kein GPRS da.
Ja, schade ist so, dass, sag ich mal gerade, wenn man so sieht, also man muss halt, weiß ich nicht, einen T68 von Ericsson haben und dann schaltet man jeden Farood-Adapter ein, damit man dann vernünftig mit dem 9210 seine E-Mess empfangen kann. Also so richtig kann es das auch noch nicht sein. Ist zwar ganz nett mit dem GPRS und mit dem Empfang, sag ich mal, von E-Mails, aber, also sage ich ja, also WAP und E-Mails und mit GPRS, was nutzt es mir, wenn ich da irgendwo bin und irgendwo einen Empfang habe und dann eine Header-Zeile bekomme, die sagt mir meistens gar nichts, sondern eigentlich möchte ich ja gerne eine E-Mail abrufen und wenn ich eine E-Mail abrufe, sag ich mal, wenn ich meine Partner davon überzeugt habe, dass ich doch gerne Text-E-Mails bekomme, dann hat es ja schon Sinn, aber weiß ich nicht, Hunderttausende von Newslettern von, weiß ich nicht, von Microsoft über Citrix, über Soschedata, also die ganzen Microsoft-Sachen, über, weiß ich nicht, Bonn-Prix und was es da alles gibt, Shibo, sind alles irgendwelche HTML-E-Mails, die ich da irgendwie bekomme und da nutzt mir das einfach gar nichts. Wenn ich da bekomme, sie haben eine neue E-Mail, weiß ich nicht, von netzbuy.com oder wie auch immer, da kriegt man dann irgendwie ein HTML-Format. Was nutzt es mir, wenn ich da so eine E-Mail mit einem Handy per Web empfange?
Ginge bei mir auch überhaupt gar nicht. Es ist einfach nicht zu managen, dieses E-Mail aufzukommen. Man kann da zwar gewisse Sachen filtern, aber der Trick ist es halt bei E-Mail, die Leute können dir die Sachen senden und du kannst es asynchron abrufen. Sie müssen da nicht vorher Bescheid sagen oder so was. Wenn du dir mit WAP die E-Mails angucken willst, dann können die Leute, wenn es irgendwas Dringendes gibt, notfalls auch anrufen oder so was in der Art. Also bei mir würde das auch nicht funktionieren, weil das Volumen viel zu groß ist.
Damit meine ich das gerade mit dem ganzen GPRS und so weiter, dieses Allways On. Eigentlich ist es doch schön, wenn man sich ganz bewusst mal irgendwo in der Pause auf dem Bahnhof oder auf den Flughafen oder irgendwo in einer ruhigen Minute hinsetzen kann. Sagt, okay, jetzt mache ich hier mal eine Hscsd-Verbindung auf. Ich meine, D2 unterstützt ja auch V110-Einwahl. Hol mir meine E-Mails, herr, da ist ab. Sag zwei Minuten online, hol mir die richtigen E-Mails ab und hab die E-Mails halten. Hab die eben, sag ich mal, wie zum Beispiel auf dem Kommunikator oder sei es Notbock und so weiter, kann die ganzen Ruhe bearbeiten. Bei JPHS, wenn ich dann irgendwo bin, Mensch, Sie haben eine neue E-Mail. Abrufen oder nicht abrufen, was kostet das? Ist das sinnvoll oder ist das sinnlos? Also, weiß nicht, da ist irgendwie so ein, für mich persönlich ein Stressfaktor irgendwo auch mit dahinter. Ich meine, wenn ich ins Büro gehe, schalte ich auch morgens einen Rechner an und sage, äh, drückchen auf dieses blöde Outlook oder Netscape oder wie auch immer, Icon oder Lotus Mail und hol mir die E-Mails, aber dann habe ich immer noch die Chance zu sagen, ach, die E-Mail ist wichtig, die E-Mail ist nicht wichtig. Wenn ich aber mit GPS, dann kriege ich die Dinge ja praktisch so, weiß ich nicht, so hinterhergebrutscht, wie verfolgt, würde ich sagen. Also mir gefällt es nicht so in dem Sinne, sondern, ich weiß nicht, viele Leute kennen ja auch, oder gerade bei den Jugendlichen, die wissen ja auch nicht, dass man erstens mit dem Telefon auch telefonieren kann und zweitens, dass das Ding auch einen Ausknopf hat.
Das finde ich ohnehin verblüffend, dass noch niemand hingegangen ist und einfach nur ein SMS-Terminal gebastelt hat.
Oh doch, gibt's doch.
Gibt's doch von Motorola, V100.
Ach.
V100 ist zum Auseinanderklappen und kann SMS tippen.
Also wirklich mit Tastatur und sonst irgendwie was.
Nokia hat doch auch so ein Ding, oder?
Völlig an mir vorbei gegangen.
Genau, Nokia hat das, wie heißt das, 5510.
Ach so, ja gut, das ist jetzt dieses Breite.
Ja, das ist aber auch Telefon mit Impact Player und so weiter und so fort.
Ich hab, wie heißt du nochmal anruf?
Andreas.
Andreas, ich hab's so ein bisschen rausgehört, du verwendest Telefone auch sozusagen jetzt in deinem Job. Zur, was genau, was machst du da, Überwachung oder was?
Es geht mehr um am Administration Überwachung. Und da braucht dich halt einfach irgendwo ein Gerät, womit ich einfach mal auf einer, also gerade Windows-Based Terminal-Server mit nem 92 hin, gibt's eben diesen Citrix ICE Client mit einer Hscsd Verbindung. Kann man halt mal irgendwo einen Command Prompt aufmachen und mal irgendwie einen Server abfragen. Ansonsten gibt's dann einen wunderbaren Telnet Client, mit dem man unter, weil ich viel unter Unix arbeite, denn bei den großen Sachen, oder die Anbindung an die Maschinen, das sind Unix, wo man halt einfach mal mit dem Telnet wunderbar arbeiten kann. Übrigens auch unter Windows 2000 kann man mit dem Telnet wunderbar arbeiten, um da irgendwelche Maschinen, sei mal Statusparameter abzufragen, einfach nur als Wartung oder mal, weiß ich nicht mal, schnell eine E-Mail zu schreiben. Also ich bin da nicht so ein T9 Fanatiker, der da irgendwie auf der Tastatur was rumtippen kann, ist ja ganz nett, auch beim 290C, dass es geht, aber eigentlich so Überwachungsfunktionen, schnelle Auswertungen und sei mal für den Fall hat auch eben die Firma, sag ich mal, eine kostenlose Einwahl per Hscsd zur Verfügung gestellt, eben genau für diese Fälle. Und da nutzt mir, sag ich mal gerade in diesen Notfällen, GPi-RS in dem Falle gar nichts, weil ich brauche eine definierte Bandbreite, um da irgendwelche Aktionen ausführen zu können. Und sag ich mal selbst beim Tele-Net, wenn ich da keine Pakete rüberkriege über die Leitung, weil er einfach der Empfang zu oder die Bandbreite nicht zur Verfügung stellt, was nutzt es mir dann, wenn ich dann always on bin, aber ich kann nicht arbeiten? Also einfach Bedienung. Einfach nur irgendwelche Sachen zu bedienen. Und GPi-RS, wie gesagt, ist ganz nett zur Verfügung. Imode, weiß ich noch nicht, habe ich leider noch kein Handy in der Hand gehabt. Also so fanatisch bin ich dann auch noch nicht, aber das sage ich. Also WAP und GPi-RS ist so eine Benachrichtigungsfunktion, ist ja ganz nett, und wenn man Zeit hat. Aber zum Arbeiten denke ich mal, das Moment, die Sache mit Metall-CSD, die auch nicht so teuer ist, muss man ehrlich sagen, selbst wenn man sich bei Valley 2 einwählt, einfach noch die vernünftige Sache.
Alles klar. Andreas, danke für deinen Anruf.
Bitte, bitte.
Und hallo, Alexander.
Hallo. Also, ich wollte so was zum Thema Wapp loswerden. Und zwar, ich bin von der ganzen Sache mit Wapp und so weiter irgendwie gar nicht so begeistert.
Warum du nicht?
Ich halte es ein bisschen für witzlos, weil ihr hattet es eben auch schon mal angesprochen mit diesen tollen Pornos bei Imode. So, Samantha Foxtrot-Poker, C64 Zeit, kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern, als ich das gespielt habe und so weiter. Es gibt ja auch diese tollen WAP-Pornos, da bin ich schon drüber gestolpert.
Ach so, diese schwarz-weiß-Dinger.
Genau, wo man raten muss, ob es männlich ist oder weiblich.
Aha, meistens heitere ich. Herma Froditen-Poker.
Und ich weiß nicht, bei dem ganzen WAP, ich bin da etwas skeptisch auf den Nutzen von sowas. Ich benutze es meistens gar nicht. Wenn ich irgendwas wissen will, ruf ich an. Da bin ich meistens schneller und im Endeffekt auch kostengünstiger.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir jetzt eine Barnauskunft hole, dann ist das anzurufen teurer. Weil die irgendwie bei so einer 0, 80er-Nummer mir da, ich weiß nicht wie viel, aber es ist einiges, aus der Tasche ziehen. Also da bin ich mit meinem WAP echt billiger dran.
Ja, kann man sehen, wie man es möchte. Okay, Service, wie so Sachen wie Bahnen, so was nutze ich halt nicht. Ich bin da doch schon lieber selber mobil.
Ach so, Auto.
Genau.
Ach so, verstehe. Alles klar, Alexander, vielen Dank. 0331 77 97 110, wenn ihr im Chaosradio 71 anruft und mit uns über Telefone sprechen wollt.
Ja, was mir im Rahmen des vorletzten Anrufs noch mal so eingefallen ist, ist, dass halt GSM mittlerweile auch sehr zu Dingen verwendet werden, die halt jetzt vom Mobiltelefonieren selbst noch mal getrennt sind. Also, es ist zum Beispiel ein Mietwagen eingebaut, um eben Rückmeldungen zu geben, dann eben nicht selten mit GPS gekoppelt. Die ganzen Alarmsysteme funktionieren so. Es wird im Lkw-Tracking, Flottentracking wird es verwendet. War da nicht auch irgendwas mit den Güterwaggons der Bahn? Stellen die das nicht auch auf GSM um, um die Dinger wiederzufinden, weil sie immer von den 50% ihrer Waggons nicht wissen, wo die eigentlich sind? Die wissen das ja nicht immer, wo die sind. Die stehen dann irgendwo, haben das schon mal so. Ich finde halt am laufenden Meter, wenn man sich die Güterwaggons sieht, die seit drei Jahren da rumstehen, mit Waren.
Glaubst du wirklich, dass die Bahn in jedem Waggon ein Handy einbaut?
Ja, genau das werden sie tun.
Der Christoph Vermögen.
Nee, das ist Pipifax.
Verbrauchst du die Technologie von vor 5 Jahren. Warum muss ich dann 500 Euro im Laden dafür bezahlen?
Wo bekommen die den Strom her?
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht bauen sie eine langanhaltende Batterie ein. Das Ding muss ja nicht sehr viel mehr machen, als alle 8 Stunden mal ein Pieps von sich zu geben.
Was mir zu den SMS Terminals übrigens noch einfällt, es war ein relativ interessantes Ding zu sehen auf der CeBIT dieses Jahr von einer taiwanesischen Firma. Die haben ein SMS Terminal gebaut in Kreditkartengröße, 3 mm dick, mit einem kleinen Display obendrauf und tasten, was man sich so in die Brieftasche stecken konnte und zum SMS verschicken von unterwegs nehmen konnte. Soll 25 Dollar marktpreis kosten.
Was haben?
Das finde ich ja dann wieder großartig.
Aber wenn es dann hier auf den Markt kommt, dann kostet es wahrscheinlich nicht 25 Dollar oder 25 Euro, sondern gleich wieder 250 oder so etwas. Wie hoch sind denn eigentlich die Herstellungskosten von so einem Gerät? Ich meine, ich kaufe, ich weiß nicht, was meins im Laden gekostet hätte, ich schätze mal ungefähr 400 Mark, also dieses ME45. Was kostet das wirklich?
Also die billigsten Geräte, die es jetzt so gibt, kosten unsubventioniert im Einkauf um die 80 Euro.
Aber doch noch so teuer, hätte ich nicht mitgerechnet. Schade, ich dachte, ich könnte die Industrie ein bisschen an.
Na gut, aber die reinen Fertigungskosten kannst du etwa ablesen, die sind schon relativ gering.
Ja, das ist einstellig. Chaosradio 71 ist sie.
Ben Fritz in Berliner Kabel. Dann 89, 85.
Äh, halb eins.
Ja, halb eins. Heute Nacht Wolken, ab und zu ein bisschen Regen bei 9 bis 6 Grad. Morgen teilweise Sonne bei 16 bis 19 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerard Kötterheim. Ja, super. Schade eigentlich. Schnellste Nachrichten.
So, jetzt geht es mit den Meldungen trotzdem los. Bei den Ermittlungen gegen die Islamistentruppe Al-Tawid ist ein weiterer Verdächtiger festgenommen worden. Die Bundesanwaltschaft teilte außerdem mit, dass in Essen zwei weitere Häuser durchsucht wurden. Gestern wurden in verschiedenen Städten 11 Mitglieder der Terrorgruppe verhaftet. Die Anschaffung des Transportflugzeugs A400M hat erneut für einen EKLAR im Haushaltsausschuss gesorgt. Die Ausschussmitglieder warfen Verteidigungsminister Scharping vor, mit finanziellen Zusagen an die Partnerstaaten den Willen des Parlaments missachtet zu haben. Der grünen Haushaltsexperte Metzger forderte den Rücktritt Scharping. Das tschechische Parlament hat eine Streichung der Bene-Kräte und eine Eigentumsrückgabe an Sudeten-Deutsche abgelehnt. Mit großer Mehrheit verabschiedete es eine Resolution, in der die Verordnungen als Folge des Zweiten Weltkrieges bezeichnet werden. Die katholische Kirche hat in den USA-Wildpriester nach schweren Fällen des Kindesmissbrauchs entlassen. Diesen Vorschlag machten führende US-Kardinäle zum Abschluss ihrer Krisengespräche im Vatikan. An eine Aufhebung des Zür-Libats ist nicht gedacht. Sportfußball im Halbfinale-Hinspiel der Champions League trennten sich Manchester United und Bayer Leverkusen 2 zu 2 unentschieden und Basketball im Player-Viertelfinale. Zweites Spiel gewann Alba Berlin gegen Bayer Leverkusen mit 92 zu 87. Damit werden wir endlich beim Verkehr. A11 Richtung Berlin zwischen Fienow-Furt und Lanke, Vollsperrung der Fahrbahn, weil dort ein Fahrzeug brennt.
Ihr seid eine kleine, aber feine Fußballmannschaft und ihr denkt, ihr könnt das Fritz-Soccer-Team schlagen? Dann holt euch den Fritz-Soccer-Team-Herausforderungszettel. Wir kommen zu euch und solltet ihr uns schlagen, behaltet ihr eure Trikots. Na, und ihr kriegt unsere noch dazu.
Den Herausforderungszettel für das Fritz-Soccer-Team gibt's unter fritz.de oder unter 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
So, noch ein paar Minuten Chaosradio 71 zum Thema Mobilfunk und was du dazu hörst.
0331, Tim bitte.
Ich hab aufgehört zu rauchen, das ist...
Ja, vielleicht solltest du wieder damit anfangen. Das ist ganz einfach. Die erste ist auch umsonst. Und hinterher erklär ich dir das mit den Spritzen. 0331 70 97 110. Falls ihr Fragen zur Technik eures Telefons oder von Telefonen im Allgemeinen oder den Netzen, die da drum rum gestrickt werden, habt. Hallo Steffen. Steffen? Du hast eine Frage?
Ja, und zwar zwei Fragen komplexe. Das erste, ich habe auch mal so ein Handy-Virus bekommen. Und zwar, ich rede nicht allzu viel mit dem Handy. Also eigentlich sind das bloß zwei Telefonpartner. Und deshalb habe ich die Vermutung, dass es von der einen da sein könnte. Und da hatte sie mich aber angerufen. Und jetzt wäre meine Frage, wenn ich diesen Virus oder SMS-Virus bekommen habe, bekomme ich da oder habe ich dann irgendwie eine Mitteilung im Speicher, den ich dann noch abrufen könnte.
In welcher Natur war denn dieses Virus?
Ja, das war so, dass ich in einer Freigabe angenommen hatte das Gespräch und einen Tag später wollte ich anrufen und das hat sich nicht gezuckt. Also ich habe auf Freigabe gedrückt und ich glaube nicht mal das Display hat sich geändert. Ich habe da irgendeinen eigenen, also eins von diesen Bildchen, die man da einstellen kann.
Was ist das denn für ein Gerät überhaupt? Was ist das denn für ein Gerät überhaupt?
3310 von Nokia.
Und du hattest sozusagen die Tastatur gesperrt und konntest sie dann nicht mehr entsperren, oder wie?
Genau.
Okay, und was hast du dann unternommen oder ist das jetzt immer noch der Zustand?
Nee, das Handy war zum Glück halb leer. Und als ich dann zwei Tage später, also ich hatte dann den ganzen Abend versucht, das wieder zu entsperren, dann hatte ich auch noch bei E-Plus angerufen. Die Dame erklärte mir, das ist doch auch bloß ein kleiner Computer. Der darf doch auch mal abstürzen. Und ich hätte Akku rausmachen sollen. Und zum Glück war am nächsten Morgen das Handy leer. Und da hatte das irgendwie dann noch... Also ich hab's nicht wieder zum Starten gekriegt, aber irgendwie hab ich bloß wahrscheinlich falsch auf diese große Einschaltaste gedrückt. Denn jemand anderes hat's dann wieder gestartet und dann lief's wieder normal.
Also wahrscheinlich hättest du einfach bloß den Akku rausnehmen müssen. Also es kommt in der Tat halt häufiger mal vor, dass die Dinger mal abstürzen.
Die Dame von E-Plus hatte nicht ganz unrecht.
Genau, also das muss nichts mit einem Virus zu tun haben oder so. Also das kommt einfach mal vor, dass die Dinger abstürzen. Also insbesondere 33er-Serie passiert einfach mal. Und dann einfach den Akku rausnehmen und wieder reintun und dann wieder einschalten und dann sollte es wieder wie gewohnt funktionieren. Ist halt wie mit einem PC zu Hause, den man halt auch ab und zu mal neu starten muss.
Auf Nokia-Handys läuft Windows?
Na, so was Ähnliches.
Was war deine zweite Frage, Steffen?
So, der zweite Fragekomplex ist, dass ich ziemlich schlecht sehen kann und eigentlich ein Handy suche, was eine freiskalierbare Schrift hat und eventuell dann auch so ein 4-Quadranten-Cursor, dass ich mir die SMS auf Displaygröße sozusagen die Schrift... Also das wäre für mich passend. Also ich habe deshalb ja einen 3310, weil das die Möglichkeit hat, große Schrift oder etwas größere Schrift. Und also ich bräuchte die Schrift am liebsten auf Displaygröße und dann mit eben rechts, links durchscrollbar. Was eine andere tolle Sache wäre, wäre eine Sprachausgabe für SMS.
Ist mir nichts bekannt, also weder eine Schrift, die Buchstaben auf ganzer Displaygröße anzeigen kann zum Durchscrollen, noch eine Sprachausgabe für SMS. Also was man höchstens realisieren könnte, ist möglicherweise eine Lösung über den Communicator, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Stimmt, das könnte sein. Also bei der Communicator ist ja relativ frei, also da kann man eigene Anwendungen draufladen. Genau, 9210, da kann man ja eigene Anwendungen draufladen. Aber ob es jetzt tatsächlich gibt, also da ist mir auch nichts bekannt.
Ich habe den Vorgänger, das war glaube ich 8210, da gab es...
3210 ist der Vorgänger vom 3310.
Oder von welchem Telefon jetzt?
Ne, von dem Communicator, der Vorgänger.
Das war 9110.
Ja, und da hatte, ich glaube TBX, der hatte für die Vorgängerversion der Software eine Sprachausgabe entworfen. Und die aber noch nicht auf die neue Software portieren können. Und das, was der Communicator an Schrift, also an Zoom bietet, das ist für mich immer noch nicht ausreichend. Also da könnte ich auch die Schrift auf Displaygröße gebrauchen. Also der Communicator hat selber schon eine Zoom-Funktion. Also ich hatte mich da kurz vorher ein bisschen bei Nokia schlau gemacht.
Radlose Gesichter, da haben wir leider keine Idee, welches Telefon da funktionieren könnte für dich.
Das sind doch nicht so die Features, die jeden Tag gefragt sind.
Ja, aber ich denke mal, das ist ein Kundenkreis, der auch nicht so ganz klein ist.
Vielleicht mal einem Hersteller vorschlagen.
Genau, das ist auf jeden Fall mal eine Anregung.
Ja, ich hatte, also als mein altes Handy jetzt auch den Akkugeist aufgegeben hat, da hatte ich kurz vorher eine E-Mail-Aktion gemacht bei eigentlich allen großen Handyherstellern. Und eigentlich, ja, auch eben die Ratlosigkeit. Aber ich denke mal, der Kundenkreis könnte, also ich denke mal gerade alte Menschen, die zunehmend dann Augenprobleme haben, die wären doch für sowas auch dankbar.
Tja, möglicherweise, aber tja.
Ja, es gibt das ja bei den normalen Telefonen durchaus, also schon beim normalen Telekom-Shop gibt es angepasste Telefone mit großen Tasten, großen Bildschirmen und so weiter. Das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis es kommt, aber ich weiß auch von nichts.
Wenn die ersten Handys mit W-Scheibe dann kommen.
Na ja, aber Steffen, vielleicht wendest du dich mal an irgendwelche blinden Organisationen oder sowas, weil die werden ja das Problem noch stärker haben, weil die sehen eben gar nichts. Vielleicht haben die auch irgendwelche selbstgebauten Lösungen, die dir eventuell weiterhelfen. Dann danke ich für deinen Anruf. Danke dir auch. Hallo Sebastian.
Ich habe mal eine Frage. Ich habe das S45 mir ungefähr vor einem Monat geholt und hatte dann ein Problem nach einer Weile, dass die Kalenderfunktion nicht mehr ging.
Ja.
Dann bin ich auch zu meinem Händler gegangen bei Vodafone und habe gefragt und die haben mir gesagt, ich soll das runterladen für so ein Setup. Und das habe ich auch gemacht. Und das ging bis dahin, dass es mir, also es stand da hier, löscht gerade hier den aktuellen Setup und am Ende dann, von der ganzen Aktion stand da keine Verbindung zum Handy.
Ach du Scheiße.
Und dann war ganz dick und jetzt...
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr an, oder?
Nein, jetzt geht gar nicht mehr.
Ja, das Problem ist, dass du die alte Software jetzt gelöscht hast und die neue aus irgendeinem Grund nicht draufgespielt wurde.
Genau.
Das ist so ein Fall von Pech gehabt. Also da musstest du es dann halt zum Service bringen, dass die dir da halt wieder die neue Software drauf spielen. Das ist halt genau der Grund, warum die meisten Hersteller, oder alle außer Siemens, das nicht machen, mit der Software selber runterladen, weil da können halt immer irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Probleme auftreten und dann passiert genau so was.
Also, wenn es zu teuer ist, stehe ich im Schacht, kann ich abgeben, das Ding.
Ja, da ist ja noch Garantie drauf. Trotzdem gute Nacht, Sebastian. Du hast einen Tipp für Steffen mit dem großen Display.
Nee, nicht mit dem Display, sondern mit der SMS-Sprachaufgabe. Und zwar gibt es doch auf dem WDR diese eine Computersendung, wo diese alten Herren immer an Computer rumbasteln.
Ich habe das hier gerade mal auf. Ich schraub, so sieht das von innen aus.
Und da hatten sie mal eine Sondersendung zu Blinden und Computern. Und da habe ich mir so ein paar Sachen angesehen, was ganz interessant war und auch was sie hatten. Daran kann ich mich noch erinnern. Die hatten mit einem Communicator, den umgebastelt oder da irgendwas mit dem gemacht. Und der hat dann Sprachausgabe gehabt.
Ansonsten fällt mir auch gerade ein, kann man doch einfach seine SMS aufs Festnetz schicken lassen. Und dann wird die vorgelesen. Das ist die ganz einfachste Sprachausgabe. Und meiner Meinung nach kann man seine Festnetzen dann auch auf sein Handy weiterleiten. Und dann hat man auch auf dem Handy die Sprachausgabe.
Ja, das mit dem Festnetz hat ein Freund von mir neulich um 6.15 Uhr morgens gemacht.
War spannend, oder?
Ja, er hat sich meine ganze Familie gefreut.
Okay, hoffentlich hat Steffen das gehört. Steffen, wend dich mal an den Westdeutschen Rundfunk. Da gibt es die Sendung Computer Club. Möglicherweise helfen die weiter. Vielen Dank dafür, Jochen. Tschüss, gute Nacht. Hallo Thorsten. Eine Frage zu SMS.
Ich bin beim E-Plus-Netz und was ich wissen möchte, ist, ob man eine Empfangsbestätigung bekommen kann, wie es bei D1 funktioniert.
Da hätte ich sogar noch eine Frage obendrauf. Sind das überhaupt echte Empfangsbestätigungen oder sind das einfach nur Bestätigungen, dass die bei dem Server mal abgegeben wurden?
Also, das ist folgendermaßen ein Doppelpunkt. Bei E-Plus gibt es immer noch keine Empfangsbestätigung. Das wollten die mal irgendwie einführen, aber das ging dann auch mal ein paar Tage und dann ging es irgendwie wieder nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung, warum sie das nicht hingekriegt haben. Also, es ist nach wie vor leider nicht möglich, eine Empfangsbestätigung bei E-Plus zu kriegen für Nachrichten, die man von seinem Handy aus versendet. Und zu Holgers Frage, ob das eine echte Empfangsbestätigung ist. Im Prinzip ja, aber. Also, wenn du die Nachricht innerhalb deines Netzes verschickst, dann ist es in der Tat auf jeden Fall zu 100% eine echte Empfangsbestätigung. Das heißt, du kriegst diese Empfangsbestätigung erst, nachdem das empfangene Handy dem Netz gesagt hat, okay, die ist jetzt hier bei mir angekommen. Und dann sagt das Netz deinem Handy, okay, die Nachricht ist angekommen. Das heißt, du weißt wirklich, die ist angekommen. Du kannst natürlich nicht wissen, ob derjenige sie gelesen hat, aber du weißt, dass sie angekommen ist. Also, es gibt da Ausnahmen, und das war bis vor kurzem, dass Gateway über das in Deutschland die SMSen zwischen den Netzen hin und her gesendet wurden. Das Dr. Materna Gateway. Da hat man dann immer nur eine Empfangsbestätigung dafür gekriegt, dass die Nachricht bei dem Dr. Materna Gateway, bei diesem SMS-Gateway, angekommen ist. Und nicht bei dem Empfänger. Jetzt gehen die Netzbetreiber aber dazu über, immer mehr zwischen den Netzen selber Leitungen zu legen. Also, zum Beispiel Viacat hat inzwischen zu allen Netzbetreibern eine SMSC-Leitung, und die anderen Netzbetreiber machen das auch immer mehr untereinander. Und in dem Prozess kriegt man dann auch immer mehr echte Empfangsbestätigungen. Also, man kann das, wenn man das jetzt mal ausprobieren möchte für eine Sache, jemandem, dem man häufig SMSen schickt, also dann kann man das mal ausprobieren, indem man dem sagt, schalt mal dein Telefon aus, und dann sendet man dem eine SMS und guckt, ob die Empfangsbestätigung gleich ankommt oder erst, wenn der sein Telefon wieder eingeschaltet hat.
Thorsten, nur jetzt noch eine Frage, ne?
Die andere Frage ist, mein Akku ist auch jetzt leer, darum brauche ich ein neues Handy. Nein, ich habe jetzt über zwei Jahre einen, und ich brauche ein neues. Und ich kriege wieder einen zu pensioniert. Und mit Siemens bin ich eigentlich ganz gut gefahren. Und mir schwebt jetzt also auch ein neues Siemens vor. Und das wollte ich wissen, welche können davon MMS, oder sind MMS-tauglich?
Also, wenn du MMS haben möchtest, dann musst du entweder noch ein bisschen warten, oder dir einen RX und T68i kaufen.
Ah ja, also nur von RX im Moment.
Genau, also das ist das einzige im Handel erhältliche. Nokia kommt jetzt die Tage mit dem 3510, das allerdings ein schwarz-weiß-Display hat, und MMS ausschließlich empfangen kann. Dann gibt es demnächst das 7650. Und von Siemens, muss ich sagen, weiß ich jetzt gar keins. Also jetzt so die, die demnächst kommen, so M50 und sowas, das hat zwar Java, aber MMS hat das auch nicht. Also habe ich auch gehört, dass Siemens da wohl noch ein paar Problemchen hat. Ja, also wenn du tatsächlich Siemens haben möchtest, kann es sein, dass du noch eine Weile warten musst, bis du ein Telefon mit MMS bekommst.
Na ja, gut, das ist auch nicht so wichtig. Ich wollte nur mal hören, ob es da schon was gibt. Oder ob man die, die man jetzt kriegt, später mit ein Update vielleicht dazu bringen kann, dass die auch MMS können.
Das glaube ich fast nicht, weil die Telefonhersteller natürlich immer gerne neue Telefone verkaufen möchten. Wie das halt immer so ist. Bei Ericsson ist es auch so, das T68, was es ja jetzt schon eine ganze Weile gibt, und das T68i, die sind hardwaremäßig baugleich, die haben zwar eine etwas andere Oberschale und so, aber die sind halt ansonsten baugleich. Das heißt, man kann prima die MMS-Software auch auf das T68 aufspielen, aber Ericsson macht das bisher nicht. Und sie behaupten immer wieder, ja, das wird es irgendwann geben, aber das wird immer noch weiter und weiter hinaus gezögert. Da kann man sich natürlich auch überlegen, dass da wahrscheinlich eher der Wunsch dahinter steht, dass die Leute sich lieber das Telefon neu kaufen, statt sich ein altes Telefon mit neuer Software dann zu holen.
Keine Ursache.
Das waren meine zwei Fragen.
Ich habe mal eine Frage zu GPRS. Ich habe auch das F45 und benutze es ab und zu mal für Web. Und ich habe das Problem, dass wenn ich mich in dieses TD1-Portal zum Beispiel einwählen will, also in ein Fremdes, ich bin bei T2, dass es nicht funktioniert. Also das Handy zeigt mir Verbindungsfehler an, wenn ich mich über GPRS bei dem TD1-Portal einwähle.
Das ist halt so die ganz natürliche, also die Netzbetreiber wollen natürlich, dass ihr tolles Portal nur für ihre Kunden verfügbar ist.
Aber über CSD kriege ich es, also kriege ich es aber, das Portal.
Wählst du dich dann über die WAP-Einwahl von T2 ein? Aha, das ist interessant.
Ne, ne, ne.
Ne, nicht von T2, sondern von E+, oder T1. Ich meine jetzt generell die Fremdnetze. Dass das natürlich bei Viac Intercom nicht funktioniert, habe ich schon Erfahrungen gemacht.
Also im Prinzip ist es halt so, wenn du tatsächlich ein fremdes Portal mit einem anderen Netzbetreiber erreichst, dann ist das eher ein Zufall. Also die Netzbetreiber sind eigentlich bemüht, die Portale untereinander auszusperren, um halt nur ihren eigenen Kunden diese tollen Angebote zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Das wunderte mich eben.
Also wenn deine Frage jetzt war, warum es über CSD geht und über GPRS nicht, es ist halt so, dass du von einem ganz anderen IP-Adressen-Range kommst, wenn du über GPRS reingehst, als wenn du über CSD reingehst. Und dementsprechend sind das halt einfach für den Netzbetreiber, der das sperren möchte, zwei ganz unterschiedliche Dinge. Also der sieht halt bloß, der kriegt halt Anfragen von einer bestimmten IP-Adresse und kann die halt aussperren. Er kann halt auch das entsprechende WAP-Gateway aussperren, aber im Allgemeinen wird halt so ein IP-Adressen-Range ausgesperrt und dann kann das halt sein, dass es bei GPRS funktioniert und bei CSD nicht oder so, aber das ist halt wahrscheinlich nur ein Versehen.
Ich informiere mich öfters mal über Connect irgendwie so. Es soll ja jetzt bald so den Nachfolger hier noch geben, die ist S45i und man kann ja das S45, das alte Software-Upgrade-mäßig übers Internet hochrüsten, indem man sich da noch was zuholt. Aber Connect sagt, man kann sich eben nicht alle Funktionen runterziehen, die dann im S45i drin sein werden. Ist das richtig? Also was wird dann das S45i mehr haben?
Habt ihr da irgendeine Ahnung?
Das weiß ich leider auch nicht. Ich weiß nur zum Beispiel beim S145 und S145i war es tatsächlich bloß der Java-Unterschied, da ist es halt auch ein reines Software-Update. Und wie das das eine Telefon zum anderen macht, das ohne i zu dem mit i. Beim S45 weiß ich das nicht. Inwieweit es da eventuell Hardware-Unterschiede geben wird oder so. Aber Siemens scheint ja generell bereit zu sein, wenn es sich nur um ein Software-Update handelt, dieses Software-Update auch durchzuführen.
Also in der Regel sind das Speicher-Unterschiede von der Größe des Speichers.
So war es zum Beispiel beim Nokia 3310 und 3330.
Genau, das 3330 hatte aufgrund des WAP-Berausatzes einfach doppelt so viel Speicher eingebaut und deswegen war vom 3310 keine Aufrüstmöglichkeit für WAP gegeben zum 3330.
Und im S45i wird da auch Java drin sein oder ist das auch nicht irgendwie?
Da habe ich leider keine Ahnung. Also S45i muss ich gestehen, ist mir auch etwas, habe ich noch gar nicht gehört. Das war mir etwas unbekannt bisher.
Also das ist noch nicht da irgendwie, aber das wurde angekündigt auf der Cebit irgendwie so in dem Zusammenhang. Also genauso wie das 6310, da haben sie jetzt ja auch ein i rangeklemmt, weil es da auch noch etwas zusätzliches gibt. Das ist ja jetzt auch relativ, nachdem der Vorgänger da war jetzt schon auf dem Markt.
Mir war halt bloß bisher das S50 und M50 bekannt als Nachfolger, von daher weiß ich, S45i hatte ich echt noch gar nicht gehört.
Das i steht für Integrierte Kalenderfunktion, die nicht abschaltet nach dem ersten Abschluss 2002.
Okay, dann wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Danke schön, gleichfalls. Ich hab hier noch eine E-Mail bekommen, die würde ich ganz gerne vorlesen, wenn der Computer nicht so weit vom Mikro weg stünde. Da fragt jemand, er hätte gehört, dass demnächst irgendein Gerät namens OXDA, Oxda, oder was auch immer. O2XDA, was ist das?
Ein Organizer.
Ein Organizer, der was kann, weil er fragt, ob es da Informationen zu gibt.
Ja, gibt's bei O2, also bei so wie FIAT jetzt halt heißt, kriegst du auf jeden Fall entweder bei Virginia.de oder bei der neuen Website www.O2Mobile.de. Da gibt's da Informationen zu, wann das Ding genau verkauft wird, ist noch unklar, und es ist halt ein Organizer, der GSM und GPRS eingebaut hat, unter Windows CE oder Pocket PC 2002, das er jetzt heißt, läuft.
Ja, gut, dann war's das jetzt auch quasi mal wieder mit dem Chaosradio Nummer 71 für heute Abend hier auf Fritz. Ich bedanke mich bei Tim, bei Tobias und bei dem Ingenieur, der nach wie vor inkognito bleiben will und das auch, ja ich kann es mittlerweile nachvollziehen. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, hier geht's gleich weiter mit dem Nightflight, mit dem Nightflight, der auch von irgendjemandem moderiert werden wird, den ich bisher... Ah ja, es ist klasse, wenn man eine Regie hat, die einem aufs Ohr quatschen kann. Hier gibt's gleich den Nightflight mit Martin Petersdorf ab eins und Chaosradio 72 gibt's am letzten Mittwoch im Mai. Bis dahin, tschüss.